- That's why we won't have a Meilyne cam.
'Cause it's just Meilyne just.
(computer keys rattling)
- Also, I don't think people want to hear
some of this stuff you
have to say, Meilyne.
- I don't want to hear some of the stuff.
- I'm glad these microphones
are super condensed
and don't pick up everything.
- People don't know
what they're asking for.
We'd have to cut so much shit
if Meilyne starts opening her mouth.
- And they're not getting it.
Also Meilyne's just a
fucking normal employee.
(all laughing)
We're not just shoving
a camera in her face.
(upbeat music)
- Hello, and welcome to another episode
of the Trash Taste podcast.
I am boss man one and I'm here
with boss man two and three.
Here to get the dub.
- Ay.
We are not the boys
anymore, we are boss men.
- We are the boss men.
(all laughing)
Why did we not call our podcast that?
Welcome to the boss man podcast.
- Oh God.
(Joey laughs)
- No, no.
- Every week is a dub.
(laughing)
- How are you boys doing?
- Good, good.
- I'm tired as all hell because-
- You're in the middle of
moving right now, aren't you?
- Well, by the time this comes out,
I would have finished moving, yes.
- Yeah.
- But yeah, like literally
tomorrow is the moving day for me.
So I have been just
scrambling for the past week.
Just like cleaning.
You don't realize how much
stuff you have in your house
until you start cleaning your house.
- It's always like that, right?
Because I remember whenever I would move,
like you start packing stuff
up and you think to yourself,
"It's gonna take a day at most."
- [Joey] Yeah!
- And you pack up like all
the main stuff in like a day.
And you're like, "Oh, I'm
90% of the way packed."
And then for some reason,
all the little shit
that just gets left over,
that takes like two days.
- Like let me introduce myself.
- Because you own like I feel like 50%
of the items you own, you
never use, think about,
but you think you need them.
- Yeah.
You also never see them either
because they're either put in a closet
or kind of out of sight somewhere, right?
- Like when you have a
colander, you need a colander,
but you don't really think about it
until you start using it or (indistinct)
you're like, "What the
fuck do I do with this?"
- We have this like shaved ice machine
that I think Meilyne got it for us.
But we had it for like the last summer
because Meilyne was like,
"Oh, I wanna like come
to your guys' place.
And the girls can have a kind of girls day
and we can just make
shaved ice or whatever."
Never used it.
(Joey chuckles)
- [Meilyne] Once!
- Okay, we used it once and
it's just this huge brick
of a thing that's just like
sitting in the kitchen.
I'm like, "Why is this here?"
(laughing)
- There's always that one
drawer in every kitchen, right?
That is just the unused appliance drawer,
right, where it's just these appliances
that people give you as gifts
or that you think is gonna be cool
when you host like that dinner
party that never happens,
and then there's just these
like random appliances
that just get put into this drawer
and you forget you even have.
- Exactly, but we have like-
- Like knives and forks.
(all laughing)
I use my hands. They're amazing.
- Yeah, but I got this kind
of cleaning service thing
because okay, one thing,
we're immediately gonna go
into this one thing I hate about Japan.
Throwing away trash, right?
And especially the big trash, right?
'Cause like in Australia-
- It's us.
- Yeah.
I'll just pick myself up.
But 'cause I don't know about in the UK,
but in Australia we have like this thing,
I think it happens once
every two or three months,
it's called like council cleanup day.
So basically what we do is
we take huge appliances,
like couches, beds, drawers,
all that kind of stuff
and we literally just throw
it out in front of the street,
like just onto the street.
- As you do.
- And basically you throw it out.
People can kind of walk around
and just grab stuff if they want.
Like if they think, "Oh, you know, I can-
- This happens every two to three months?
- It's like every two to
three months or something.
- How have I never seen this?
- Really?
- Have you seen this?
- In Australia, yeah, it happens.
I don't know if maybe
that's just like the area
that I grew up in?
- Yeah, in the UK I don't
think there's enough space
to just throw you stuff-
- Oh, I thought you were talking
about Japan for a second.
- No, no, no, not in Japan, in Australia,
in Australia we have that
where we just throw stuff out
and then big garbage truck basically comes
and collects all the stuff
that doesn't get picked up
after like a week I think.
- Right.
- Japan doesn't work like that,
so we had to throw away our bed,
which is a queen size bed, a couch,
and couple of tables and a
sofa and stuff like that.
A lot of big stuff.
But like you can't just throw it out
with the rest of the trash.
Either you have to go to
your like local council
and be like, "I want to
throw this stuff away."
And they give you these like tickets
that you have to pay for.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- To basically be like, "All right,
I'm throwing this out on this day
and then you throw it out onto the street.
- And you have to book it and tell them-
- You have to book it.
- And you have to tell
them the exact measurements
of the thing so they
can plan out the truck.
- Or, what I've found
out, is you can just,
there's just services out
there that you can just call up
and be like, "I want to
throw all this crap away."
How much is it to get rid of?"
- Yeah.
- Little more expensive than
the whole council thing,
but so much easier.
- Oh, I can imagine it is.
- I mean, it's not the price to me.
It's like we talked about last week,
it's just getting the paperwork done.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- That, like fucking I'm scared of.
- Yeah, exactly.
And like I'm not even finished
with the fucking paperwork, dude,
'cause we'll have to
do more after we move.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause Japan is just like
a never-ending sea of paperwork.
(Garnt laughs)
But like, I was like okay,
I'm getting rid of this giant bed,
I'm getting rid of this couch,
this table, all these like big appliances.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And I'm like, okay, well
these are the big things gone.
So, you know, maybe like 30%
of my belongings probably gone.
It was more like 3%.
(all laughing)
- I feel like in like
your bedroom or office
there's so many little things
that you just never think about--
- Especially my office-
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And my office has
so many little things,
I'm just like I'm...
Well, first of all,
I'm looking forward to the
moving company coming in
and seeing like all of
like my FAKKU skateboards
and shit like that.
Just being like, whoa!
- They'll be like, "Yo, is
that a rem, 1/8th scale?
- Like, "Damn, son!"
- You're just like giving
them a tour of your house.
Being like, "Yeah, so
this is the JoJo section-
- My free office tour.
(all laughing)
No, actually, to be
fair, when the moving guy
first came in to check to see what we had,
he walked into my office
and he was like, "Whoa!"
(all laughing)
- Otaku's dream, man.
- He was like, "Wow,"
Jesus, this guy's got
a fucking collection!"
- I had like the opposite happen
where like I only use my
tatami room to film in-
- [Joey] Hmm.
- And I only use it,
so I have a big tatami room
that I normally do the cosplay videos in.
and I'm really bad, so I
never clean them up after,
I just leave the cosplays
there until I do the next video
and then I clean it up.
And then one time, they didn't
tell me they were doing this,
but there was like a,
they were checking the fire
alarms in the building.
And I was like, "Yeah,
sure, come in, come in."
And he's going around my house.
He goes into my office, you know, he looks
and he's like, "Oh."
I'm like, "Yeah, I like JoJo."
He just looked at me like
I was a fucking weirdo.
And I was like, "All right, thanks buddy."
(all laughing)
And then as he went to my tatami room,
I was like, "Oh, shit, I just remembered
that all my shit was in there."
And so I go into check that he's there
and this man is just standing
in the middle of like
my cosplay everywhere.
The stuff reeked.
Just holding up something
to the fire alarm,
just looking like,
"Look down, don't look, don't
look, don't look at anything."
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
And then after this guy
left really awkwardly,
an hour later, someone else came along
from the same company in the building
and did the exact same thing.
And I was like, "Wait, why
am I being checked twice?"
- Oh, was he like a spot-man?
- I don't know, I was-
- "Just gonna make sure my
friend got it right." You know?
- He's like, "Yo, I heard
there's free cosplay.
Where's it at?"
And then I had the exact
same interaction again,
where I was like, "Oh yeah, sorry about
the mess in this room."
- By the way, I like JoJo.
- By the way, I also like JoJo.
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
"Oh, really, huh?"
Fucking weirdo.
- Yeah.
But luckily as I said, I'm
pretty sure I mentioned
in the previous podcast episode,
but like we've got a service
where they just do all the packing for us.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- My God, I can not imagine if
I had to do that all myself.
- God, I just kind of realized
what I'm gonna have to
go through when we move,
because my room's gonna be fine,
but then I got Sydney's room.
(laughing)
Which the amounts of
fucking fucked-up shit
in Sydney's room...
- Whoa, be careful
that's the pussy of the-
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
That was expensive!
- So I remember this one time
we had to get our doorbell fixed, right?
- [Joey] Hmm.
- So we thought our
house was pretty clean.
Basically, whenever
someone needs to come in
to check our house at
all, we just make sure
Sydney's room is just fucking locked off.
(Joey laughs)
It's like a quarantine section, you know.
- You gotta put up like a-
- Like Chernobyl.
He's like, "You can't go in there.
There's an inclusion zone."
- You gotta put up
like the R18 curtains
straight to the doorway, right?
It's like, "Only adults allowed."
- You put the fucking
biohazard sign on the door
just to make sure no one gets in, right?
- That's radioactive.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So how we learned our lesson
was we had our doorbell fixed
and of course Sydney's
room was like cordoned off,
but we forget that sometimes Sydney
just has shit lying
about the house, right?
And I guess we've just
become so desensitized
to some of the stuff she reviews.
- Right.
- My fiance reviews,
a lot of lewd stuff.
That's her channel.
So we just had like a bunch of figures
that were just left in the living room
with just like their tits out, right?
(Joey laughs)
- Living room material.
- As you do.
- What living room would
be complete without-
- Oh, I see you've see my decor.
- Oh, that's the "Mother Knows Breast,"
size real scale, you know.
- So this guy just comes in, right?
And the doorbell's like
right next to the kitchen.
And also we have a shelf
right next to the kitchen,
which just has two lewd,
completely naked figures
just right next to where the doorbell is.
- Right!
- He takes a look,
looks at the figures, looks at Sydney
and just doesn't make contact
with Sydney ever again.
(laughing)
- Has he got Hentai hair?
- Yeah.
- Like Hentai hair, his
hair's covering his eyes?
- Just sweating.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah, and that was probably
the longest fucking hour
he had to like enjoy of his life
when he was just fixing the doorbell.
- I love how he immediately
looked at Sydney.
You wouldn't think that like,
you'd look at like Garnt, right?
Being like this mother fucker right here.
Just like leaving his lewd shit out.
No, immediately went to Sydney.
- He's like, "God, I wish that was me.
I wish my wife would let
me put my dirty figures
in the living room."
- Yeah, it's the one time,
whenever someone comes round
and I'm just like, "Yo, these lewd stuff,
that's not me guys, guys, that's not me.
It's just my partner."
- You just like silently point at Sydney.
- No, no, seriously, seriously.
It's my partner this time.
(laughing)
- Yeah, I mean, I had to like,
'cause I have quite a few
doujins and stuff like that
in my bookshelf as well.
So I was like, I'll pack
these away before I...
'Cause I'm with these
guys for a couple of days.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- I don't want an awkward
experience for a couple of days
as they like sift through
my doujins being like,
"So what's the fragile stuff
and what's not the
fragile stuff," but yeah.
So because of that, I have
just been so incredibly busy.
I haven't been able to like sit down
and like playing any games.
I mean, Pokemon Snap came
out like a few days ago.
Haven't been able to like
download that shit at all.
- You're not ahead on
videos anymore, are you?
which is just like, I
heard that about Joey
and I'm just like,
""What what is going on?"
- Dude, I think this comes
out end of May, right,
but it's like the slowest
month I've ever had,
like I think my next
video is not coming out
for like 12 days or something,
I'm like, "Fuck,"-
- Oh my God.
- My career is over dude.
I used to upload daily.
- It's just like the
signs of the apocalypse
is happening.
- Yeah, right?
- The fucking sky's falling
and Joey's not ahead on video.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- That's how I know at the end is coming.
- I'm so not ahead,
that I'm falling behind.
Fallen and I can't get up.
- Yeah, I missed an upload as well
and it like killed me.
I apologized on my YouTube
page and people were like,
"You don't have to apologize."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'm like, no.
I'm like, no I do, I do.
No, I'm not apologizing for you.
I'm apologizing to me.
- Yeah.
- Because that's the thing, right?
It's like 12 days to the
average YouTube viewer
is like whatever.
There's no difference between
seven days between videos
and like two weeks between upload.
- Yeah.
- But to the person
who makes it, it's like, "Oh, no."
- Yeah, yeah, it's everything.
It's all I think about, these damn videos.
- You know, this is the
first time in my career where
I've been ahead on videos so I'm just like
damn, I have some free time.
- Look at us!
(all laughing)
- 2021, he turns the tables!
- Garnt uploads more than Joey or Connor?
What?
Oh my god.
- Not yet, maybe one day-
- Maybe one day.
- I'll be back, I'll be back, don't worry.
- Let's play a game then. Come on.
Let's do it.
(Joey laughs)
Wait until Garnt discovers
Five Nights at Freddy's, guys.
- Yeah.
- It's game over.
- So yeah, I mean, now
that fucking lockdown's
been happening again-
- Hmm.
- I guess we can pull a-
- For the 17th time
or whatever time it is.
- For the 17th time.
I don't know, locked down in
Japan has been weird, right?
- It's a roller coaster, it goes like,
the cases go up, they
announce a shitty lockdown
that's like two more rules added.
- Hmm.
- And then they go,
"Okay the case is good now."
And then they go back up again
when they let go of restrictions
and then this happened like
the what, the fourth time now?
- Yeah.
- So we're just doing the
same shit over and over again.
- But this locked down
is the shortest ever,
it's only two weeks or something?
- Yeah, I think they-
- What's gonna change in two weeks?
- What's the point?
- I think they literally
just wanted to be like,
"Oh, Golden Week's happening?
Let's have it not happen."
- Can you explain what Golden Week
is to the viewers who don't know?
- Yeah, so Golden Week is this week
during the first week of May,
as we're recording this,
we're in the middle of it right now
where it's basically just
a bunch of public holidays
back to back to back to back to back.
- Hmm.
- So I think, yeah,
so basically people just get a week off.
- Do you know how I remember Golden Week?
- Hmm?
- It was the one week
of the year aside from like New Years
where Mangakas would take a break
from their weekly manga schedule.
So I'm just like, oh,
"One Piece" is on break?
What the fuck's Golden Week?
- Oda's like, "Thank God, finally!"
- Everything's on fire
like, I didn't get "One Piece" this week?
(Garnt chuckles)
- That's the only reason
I knew of Golden Week
before moving to Japan.
- Yeah, exactly.
Well because I think,
Japan needs Golden Week
because Japan's one of the few countries
that works on Christmas.
- Hmm.
- You know?
Like Christmas is just like,
I think everywhere else,
Christmas is like a
public holiday or at least
in Australia.
- Christian world.
- Well, yeah, like in
Australia, it's the second half
of December until maybe
the first week of January,
like three weeks, it's
just full on holiday.
- Fucking Christmas here's
is just Valentine's Day 2.0.
- Yeah, basically.
- It is.
- It really is.
- Who gives a shit?
- Yeah, but that was just like,
"Oh, I don't have a partner, finna work."
(Garnt chuckles)
- It's either you're on a date
or you are working on something.
- Yeah, exactly.
So I guess like, you know, to
Japan, they need Golden Week
because it's the one time
where they're almost forced
to take the week off
because otherwise they get,
I mean, you know, people
still are just like,
"No, fuck it, it's still
working week for me.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- My whole favorite thing of
all the Japanese Government's
lockdowns is that they did
during the whole pandemic,
the government thought
of this amazing idea
called go-to travel,
(Joey cackles)
which is just like-
- Oh yeah, that was a thing!
- This is just the funniest-
- Oh, yeah!
- This is the funniest fucking thing.
So Japanese Government,
they were losing a lot of money obviously
from tourism that they weren't getting.
So in the middle of like the pandemic,
this is like months ago, this is before,
this is last year.
- This was during the
first lockdown, wasn't it?
- Yeah, yeah.
They were like, "Guys,
we're losing too much money
in our travel economy.
We need to put some money back into it.
What we're going to do is, guys,
we're gonna give you 30% off everything
and we're gonna pay
you money to go travel.
We'll give you 200 bucks to spend,
depending on how much you spend."
- Yeah, you get coupons
at your destination.
- Yeah, yeah.
- They were like, "Oh yes,
so like it's a lockdown."
But also if you travel, 30% discount!"
- Hey!
- "Here's some money to spend,
go treat yourself, king,
but don't leave the house
thought, but don't leave."
And then they realized it
was a colossal mistake.
Like a month later, when
the cases went up a fuck ton
because everyone's of course,
everyone's gonna travel!
- Exactly, you're paying me to travel
and you don't want me to travel.
- Yeah, like if you went
to a five-star hotel
that's like a thousand bucks,
it would go down to like
600 and then you'd be given
300 bucks to spend and it's
like who isn't gonna do that?
Like if you have disposable income,
anyone is gonna do that.
- That's like dangling a
carrot in front of a horse
and telling the horse not to run, right?
(Connor chuckles)
Like don't, don't!
- I'm finna, I'm finna try
and be responsible here
but you Japanese government
making me act up.
I want, you know?
I was like, well shit,
I'm going to Hokkaido.
See ya, guys.
- Of course everyone
abused the out fuck out
of that system, right?
- Yeah, because I--
- Everyone went traveling.
- Yeah, because it was
like, why wouldn't I?
- I went to like four different places.
I was like-
- Oh my God!
- I'm obviously not, 'cause
literally everybody is going.
Right? So it's like what's the point?
What's the point of not going?
- It was the most confusing period ever,
because they were like, "Don't
travel, but please travel,
please, please travel, we
need it for the economy."
- And then they shut it down, like after-
- Yeah, like a month.
- A month, yeah.
- Of course, it was a colossal mistake.
(laughing)
- I went to Hokkaido cause
I was like, "Fuck, yeah!"
I didn't interact with anyone-
- I mean, I think all three
of us went to Hokkaido
at different times, right?
- Exactly. Why the fuck wouldn't I?
- I went way after and
it was because you guys
kept talking about
Hokkaido, and I was like,
"Okay, I think it's my time
to go to Hokkaido as well."
Waited for lockdown to
end and I was just like,
"Damn, they weren't joking around.
Fucking Hokkaido slaps, man!"
- [Joey] Exactly, exactly.
- It's like middle of fucking
nowhere, no-one's there,
it's like great, it's peaceful.
- [Joey] Yeah, it's fantastic.
- But it was just the dumbest thing ever
because if they just kept,
like this is the whole thing
that the Japanese government are doing
where they just kind of
haven't really committed to anything.
- Yeah.
- They haven't really told
you not to do anything.
They've been very wishy-washy.
- I think that's the thing.
Every restriction they've given,
it seems very half-assed
from my perspective.
It's not been like, we've
never been fully open,
but we've also never
been fully closed either.
- Yeah, like they've never
said you can't travel around.
The worst thing-
- Oh, if anything, they reward you for it.
- Yeah, yeah yeah.
- And then they also said like,
"Oh yeah, restaurants, please
close at eight," you know?
Like suddenly for some reason,
people are just gonna magically stop
getting infected before eight?
- Yeah.
- Right.
- I mean, this new
lockdown, they were like,
"Restaurants can't serve
alcohol anymore," right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And I'm just like, so I'm still allowed
to go to the restaurant?
- Yeah, yeah.
- But I just can't drink beer?
- It's generous to even
call it like half-measures.
It's like-
- Like a quarter-measure.
- A one-tenth measure is what they do.
And, you know, I don't know.
I don't really care about
the whole politics at all,
but I wish they would just
decide what they want to do.
- Well that's the problem, isn't it?
Is that unlike a lot of
countries, the Japanese,
Japanese law, they can't force
establishments to close down.
- Yeah.
- Like a lot
of other countries.
And so they're like, "Okay,
so we can't force you
to close down, but we advise
you to not serve alcohol,
to close after eight," but
there's also from what I heard,
there's like a penalty for establishments
that don't follow those rules.
- You get a fine.
- If you make a fuck-ton of money,
the restaurants that make so much money
were like, "Oh, we'll just pay the bill."
- The penalty is so low that
there are a lot of restaurants
out there, especially in like inner Tokyo
that are just like, "We'll
pay for the penalty, fuck it."
- Some of like the biggest restaurants
I think just pay the fine.
- Yeah, they just pay the fine.
but they make more off of
the money that they make.
- Yeah. Right.
- Yeah.
Then also the biggest that
was not even the fine,
it was like, "We'll put
you on a list of companies
that stayed open."
(Garnt chuckles)
And obviously to a lot of Japanese people
that's like pretty like, fuck,
we're gonna be on a list?
- Yeah.
- Fuck.
But then for some of them, they were like,
"I don't fucking give
a shit about a list."
- It's like getting on the naughty list
on Santa's-
- Yeah, Yeah.
- It's like, "Oh, no."
- It's so, so dumb, so dumb.
- That's the thing, this would have been,
at least in Japan-
- Well, 'cause Australia
and New Zealand, like totally locked down.
- Yeah.
- New Zealand were like, "No."
- Yeah, no.
- No one could do anything.
- Australia locked down for
like nine months, like fully.
And people couldn't go outside
for more than an hour a day.
And like all restaurants were closed,
all that kind of stuff.
And then when in Sydney, at least,
we got one case and the entire city
went into lock down for like a month.
Meanwhile, Japan is like, "1,000 cases?
Don't drink at restaurants."
(all laughing)
It's like, cool, thanks.
- Yeah, but I mean, it'll
be interesting to see
what happens in this next year
because every other country seems to be
getting their vaccines
and we are still like,
we're probably not gonna
be able to get our vaccines
this year if we stay in Japan.
- Right.
- It's looking more and more likely.
- Well, I mean, you know, there's like,
I know of a few of my
American friends who are here,
who are probably just
gonna like bite the bullet
and just go back to America
sometime this year to
just go get the vaccine.
- Yeah.
- Everyone in like my age
in America is already getting it.
- Yeah, exactly.
- In the UK as well, right?
- Yeah, UK as well.
- Yeah.
- It's like being a kid again,
when they always got the games before you.
It's like fuck, man, why you
all getting the good shit?
What the fuck?
- It's reversed now.
Japan is the last one to get it out.
- Exactly.
- It's like Japan was always the first.
Now, you're the last.
- I feel like I've been lied to.
- Like are you guys gonna do it?
- Yeah, I'm probably gonna do it.
- I mean, I don't blame you.
I'd fucking do it.
If I was an American or from the UK,
I would absolutely do it.
- It's twofold for me, right?
Because I want to-
- I want go back to the UK.
- I want to go back to
UK to visit my friends.
- I want beans and toast God damn it!
- You know, it's been like,
I think this is longest I've been
from like seeing my
family, seeing my friends.
- Yeah, same.
- Same, yeah.
- So I'm just like, that and the vaccine,
if I can get everything
done in one trip, then yeah,
I'm gonna take like a
month and a half off Japan
and just go do the things that
I need to do for my health.
And also catch up to all the things like-
- Beans and toast, just wanna have it.
I just wanna have some
beans and fucking toast.
- Fuck my friends, just beans and toast.
- Right, there's no Heinz beans here.
What the fuck am I supposed to do?
- That's so fucking depressing man.
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
- I legitimately miss beans and toast.
- I'm sorry-
- I crave it.
- I don't think there's
a more depressing sight
than just beans on toast by itself.
I'm sorry.
As a Brit-
- Listen,
baked beans tastes good.
- As a Brit,
like seeing the sight of
just like beans on toast
as like a fucking
breakfast, dinner, whatever.
- It's fantastic.
- See, I feel that way, nut
like two or three times a year,
I just wake up and I'm like, fuck,
I could go for some beans right now.
- Baked beans-
- Beaked beans, like Heinz
baked beans I'm like ah.
- Great source of protein
as well. You know?
Like what's not to like?
- It's like fuck me up.
- Beans are magical,
they're fucking fantastic.
- Make me fart like a mother fucker,
but still good.
- Who cares? Who cares?
I like that.
It feels like you're being cleansed.
- It's like detox.
(laughing)
But like, that's the problem, right?
It's like, at least you guys
and like all my American friends
have a choice to do that, right?
Go back, doubly like get a vaccine-
- I just saw like Australia
apparently made it illegal
to return if you're from India, right?
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- Like illegal, like
you could go to prison
if you return.
- That makes sense.
- It's just like what?
- Yeah.
- Well that's the problem, right?
Is that like, I can't do
the same for Australia
because we're in no
rush to get the vaccine
because no one's had COVID
for the past four months.
So like, not even my grandma,
who's like 92 this year
has gotten it yet.
It's like maybe-
- You guys are isolated as fuck.
It's hard enough to get
in your country as it is.
- Exactly. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- I mean, it makes sense, right?
But like, you know, that's
why Australia has done so well
and same with New Zealand, but still.
- That's why if like the
whole world goes through
like the fucking apocalypse,
Australia is just gonna
be there fucking chilling.
- Australia and New Zealand
are gonna be like the
two remaining countries.
- Exactly, right?
- Nothing goes in, nothing comes out.
- Man, seeing the whole like
the whole Joe Rogan controversy
about all the like vaccines and stuff.
It's so frustrating that like,
it's literally been the only
thing anyone can talk about
for the past like year and a half is COVID
and all this shit.
But it's also like, you can't talk about
because everyone's fucking
turned it into a political thing.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Where it's just like, I
just wanna eat baked beans.
- I just don't want to die.
- I just don't want to be ill
and I don't want to get other people ill.
- Yeah and it sucks that
it's become like a thing,
like even now talking about
it, I feel like, fuck,
there's probably gonna to
be some fucking assholes
in the comments who are
like annoyed about it,
I was talking about it and shit.
- I just want to kiss my
homie's good night, man.
- Exactly.
- Come on, man.
Let me kiss my homies. Fucking hell.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I just wanna eat some fucking baked beans,
watch "Cars 2" in the theater, you know?
- Well, I mean, wasn't
it like the UK recently,
I think like couple of days ago?
Just had their first mask-less concert?
It was like 5,000 people
at a concert or something
and none of them were wearing masks
because they were all vaccinated.
- I'm not sure about, Meilyne,
can you like play fact checker?
- I'm pretty sure I saw
that this morning, but like,
I'm not surprised either
because the UK has been,
I mean the US and UK have been
so fucking good with their vaccines.
- I loved how in the UK where
they literally were like,
"Okay guys, I think you can
maybe go out for drinks now."
Literally like the first
day, London was like rammed.
(all laughing)
- Of course.
- Of course it would be.
- And they were like, "We've
been waiting like 10 years
for this, we're gonna go
get a pint with Jerry."
It's like, oh my God.
- Exactly.
- I can't quite imagine
how Wetherspoons was going to be like,
as soon as they opened up.
- Oh my God.
- God, I do miss
a good Wetherspoons actually.
- The government could tell,
like if Britain had to fight
in like another war, you know,
and the government was
like, "Please fight,
please fight for us."
And they'd be like, "Nah, nah."
They're like, "Pubs will
be open if you fight."
They'll be like, "Where are we fighting?
Where are we fighting?"
I don't know what it is
about pubs and British people
but like it turns them into
something like ferocious.
Like when pubs come into the equation,
they become like different
people that like,
they suddenly become more passionate.
- Yeah.
I feel like people in Britain
weren't taking like the pandemic seriously
until pubs started closing down.
And that's like the-
- It's the end of the world!
(all laughing)
- They're like I sleep.
I can't go to school or work, whatever.
Pubs are closed? What the fuck!?
What the fuck!?
- This is a political agenda.
How dare they close the pubs!
- That's the exact
moment it got political.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, the pubs closed down.
I can't believe these
politicians have done this.
Oh my God.
- [Meilyne] It was supposedly
the first almost normal concert.
- Yeah.
The first almost normal concert, yeah.
- Okay, damn, okay.
- If I know British people though
we fucking lie about
anything to get into events
and stuff.
- That's true.
- They'd be like, "Yeah,
I've got a vaccine.
Of course, I've got a vaccine."
- Yeah. Oh my arm hurts. Ooh.
- Tell me if the Pendulum weren't playing
(all laughing)
I know British people.
Come on, that's a fucking
lie. There's no way.
- Come on.
- There's no fucking way.
- The amount of clubs with
like 16 and 17 year olds
with fake IDs, come on.
People are faking the passports vaccines.
- Oh, 100%.
- Vaccine passports
or whatever.
- Like the fucking bouncers give a fuck.
- Yeah.
- Are you kidding me?
- True, true.
- You could hand a fucking McDonald's
like 10 coffee card at them as an ID,
they'd let you fucking
in the club in the UK.
Get out of here.
- To be fair though,
if any country is probably going to do
like a fully normal concert first,
it's gonna be the US or the
UK with how they're going.
- Yeah, I mean.
- Whether they should.
- Yeah, when they should is
a different question but-
- I mean, from what I've heard
from like third party information,
from all my mates back there up,
it's the one thing that
we've been doing well
about the pandemic, which
is the vaccine response.
Right?
- Right.
- Which it kind of makes sense.
- Yeah, we just fucking
bought them all up.
Fuck you other countries.
- We used that first world country money.
Give us that shit.
- It's pretty tragic though.
It's just like US/UK bought them all
and then no one else gets it.
- Exactly.
- What the fuck?
It's pretty tragic really.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you get it
from the insiders there,
like, "Yeah, we're doing great."
And then you get over to-
(all laughing)
Yeah, of course you are.
- How's the rest of the world doing?
- Ah, fuck 'em.
That's their attitude, right?
It's pretty tragic.
- True, true.
- It is what it is I guess.
- Money talks.
- Exactly. Exactly.
- What do you guys been
doing in the meantime?
You guys been traveling around?
You've been doing anything
interesting before the lockdown?
- Well, before lockdown for a minute
we could travel in the
little bits that we could.
We recently just went camping which was-
- I know, I couldn't come.
I had plans I did really far in advance
and I was like, wait, shit,
I wanted to come camping with the boys.
- Yeah, so Garnt, me, and
like four of our friends
went camping in the mountains of-
- Yeah, it was my first
experience camping in Japan
and definitely was a very
different experience.
If you've never been camping before,
I recommend you go camping in Japan
'cause it is like (indistinct)
baby mode camping, right?
- Yeah, it really is.
- You roughly described it to me,
but you're saying there's
like electricity, there's-
- Okay, okay.
So let me tell you about this. Right?
So I've only been camping
I think once or twice
else in my life, okay?
- So wait, okay, I have one question.
Did you get like a lot?
- What's that?
- Like a square?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah.
We had to book it.
- We had to book a lot.
So my only other experience camping
has been just like in the
middle of the fucking fields.
Like I went on like a trip in Colorado
where we just like rode
horses for eight hours.
And we camped literally
in the middle of like
the woods in Colorado.
That was what I thought-
- That sounds fucking fantastic.
- It was fucking great.
I thought it was gonna
be something similar.
So I'm not that experienced in camping.
So I asked the boys,
"So what should I be bringing?"
Right?
And so they gave me the
usual sleeping bags,
tents, warm clothes and everything,
and also like a power
bank to charge your phone.
So I came in with the expectations of
I need to buy a big fucking power bank,
'cause we're not gonna have
any power there, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We were camping for like two days.
This episode is sponsored by Bokksu.
- Boys, get those disgusting
American chips out of here
because this episode
is sponsored by Bokksu!
An authentic Japanese
snack box subscription
that sends you small
delicious treats from Japan.
- This month, Bokksu is kicking off summer
with a tropical travels themed box.
These snacks bring you flavors
from down south in Kyushu
and Okinawa with exotic
flavors like native citrus
and local seasonings.
Now, if that doesn't sound fancy,
I don't know what does.
What do we got in the box, Garnt?
- Well, let me tell you.
We've got Shima Togarashi
rice crackers and peanuts.
Marui Chinsuko Kabosu Nuts Sable Cookie.
And more!
- Perfect pronunciation.
(laughing)
- Fuck. Nailed it!
- But guys wait, there's more!
This month snack tea pairing is
Higa Granny's Sanpin Cha Jasmine Tea.
These aren't like their competitors box
who partners with
Japanese artisanal makers
to bring you authentic flavors.
- We said it before and
we're gonna say it again.
This is cross cultural
pollination like never before.
So use our link and code
trashtaste10 in the description
to get 10% off your own Bokksu now.
Repeat customers get a
theme box every month.
Back to the episode.
- So a friend had a, he
has this thing called
like the Omnicharge.
I can't remember the full name,
but it looked like a battle station.
I remember he-
- It's not that big.
It's kind of like this.
- Yeah. Yeah.
But like it was way bigger than any
of the portable charges I've ever seen.
And also like what sold me
was that it had it's own plug,
so you can plug like-
- Power outlet.
- Like an AC adapter.
- Yeah, so you can plug like
power adapter to it, right?
So I was like I want something
like that for a camping trip.
Right?
- Yeah.
- So I asked, "Oh, what's
this thing called?"
So he says, "It's the Omnicharger."
So I Google it on Amazon
and unfortunately they're not
selling on Amazon anymore.
So I go to like the first link
that's recommended for like that search.
And here's the thing about Amazon,
is that you see a charger, right?
There's nothing to like quantify
how big this charger is.
Right?
- Just from the image.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I mean, there's dimensions
but you might not look at them.
- Sometimes it's like
buried in a wall of text.
- Yeah, it's buried in wall of text
so I just see this block, right?
- And I'm just like, it's
probably around the same,
I mean, it's recommended from
me searching the Omnicharger
so it's probably about
the same size, right?
- Fucking A.
- It's probably around the same size.
Thinking back, like
being like an electronic
and ex electronic and electrical engineer,
I've got a master's, I should have seen
like the amount of like charge it holds.
But I didn't look at the
amount of charge it holds.
I was just like on like
fucking autopilot mode.
I'm just like, okay, that looks good.
Buy that, okay.
So I wait a few days from
all my camping equipment
that I bought, and this
fucking massive package, like-
- I wish you brought it with you today.
- I wish I did. I wish I did.
This massive package
gets delivered to my door
and I'm all right.
Everything's like boxed up
so I don't know what everything is.
So the first thing I pick
up, it's fucking heavy.
It's this fucking brick and
my first thought was, oh no,
have I bought like a sleeping bag
that's just like 10 times
heavier than I need it?
- Right, right.
- And so I start unboxing it
and I see this fucking brick
just in my hands, right?
(laughing)
And I'm just like, what the fuck is this?
I don't remember buying
anything this heavy.
- Yeah.
- Turn it around
and it's the fucking charger.
And I'm like, no way.
- How big is it?
- This must be a mistake.
- I think I have a photo of it.
- So Joey has a photo.
It's on screen right now.
The photo of this brick that I got.
I turn it around.
I look at like the
appliances that it can power.
And it's just like, okay,
so this can power phones.
It can, you know, charge tablets.
And then it says you can charge laptops.
It can power a fucking mini-fridge.
(all laughing)
- Okay, okay.
- And I'm just like, it
can power a mini fridge,
a microwave and I'm just like, oh shit,
what the fuck have I bought?
- This thing he bought it
literally is like, oh, I found it.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- So this is like a fucking
brick that I bought.
- That's like two routers
strapped together.
- Yeah, yeah.
And I'm just like, what the fuck-
- It's like a Mac mini.
- I don't know what I'm going
to be able to do with this
'cause like I can't take that on a plane
'cause like if I take on a plane,
the TSA probably thinks I'm
gonna bomb the fucking plane.
- You'll get fucking
arrested on that plane.
- Like I'm probably gonna
put on the fucking ISIS list
if I take this on a plane.
Jesus Christ.
So I can't even, so I'm
just thinking to myself,
All right, guys, I've made a mistake.
But it's okay because
at least I can use it
on this camping trip.
So like I lug this massive
fucking brick in my suitcase
or in my bag, sorry,
which is probably like by itself,
the heaviest single object
in my bag for a camping trip.
And so we get to this
campsite and you know,
we get a lot and we start
unpacking everything
and I see this metal box, right?
I see this metal box.
And I was just like, "What
the fuck is that metal box?"
My first thought was, oh,
it's probably like a safe
they provided, right?
'Cause I hear about
some American campsites
having like bear safes or something
so I was thinking, oh, it
might be a safe or something.
And so I was like, "Nabi, what's that?"
And he's just like, "Just
wait, Garnt. Let me show you."
He opens it up and it's
a fucking power outlet.
(all laughing)
- Two power outlets are
sticking out like that,
I'm just like.
- Ah yes, camping with my power outlet.
- And I'm just like, "So wait,
there's literally no fucking reason
for me to buy this fucking brick
and lug this around.
I can't take it anywhere,
can't take it on the plane.
and apparently it's
useless for a camping trip.
What the fuck do I need this for?
- Literally, I looked at
that thing and I'm like,
"That's what people use
for like emergencies."
When like your house is flooded
and you have no electricity
and like this is the
thing that like powers
your house for like a month.
- I'm just thinking if
Japan Sinks ever happens,
I'm fucking sorted, man.
- You are like the top of the hierarchy.
Like people could be fighting-
- You could power
like a flood light.
- No, because I remember the first night
he like charged his phone.
Well, he was like, "Might as well use
this fucking thing I bought"
So he charged his phone, right?
It was like a 100%.
Next morning, phone is fully charged. 97%.
He used 3% of his charge
to power his phone.
I'm like this thing could last you
like literally like two months.
- Yeah. I literally-
- It's insane.
- I literally bought it just
so I could recharge my phone
during the duration of this camping trip.
- Doesn't it have like
it's own ventilation,
like fan inside of it?
- Yeah, yeah, I knew it was
like fucking way too overkill
when I opened it up, it had
a vent that had like a fan.
- He turned it on and it
literally started going (buzzing).
(all laughing)
- Well, yeah so, 3% to power
the fucking fan probably.
1% but he charged his fucking phone.
- It was so funny.
Yeah, but like I've been camping
quite a bit in Australia.
Like my dad and I used to go camping
all the fucking time.
- I don't want to fucking
camp with a power outlet.
What the fuck?
- Yeah, exactly.
But like I realized, okay,
Japan does not know how to go camping
because like it really is
baby mode on (indistinct).
- So we had like some
relatively small tents, right?
- Did you have neighbors?
- Yeah. We had neighbors.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah.
That's that's the thing
that really put me off.
- But it was one lot apart so
there was social distancing.
(laughing)
- It was one lot apart,
it was social distancing.
- Are you kidding me?
I bet he could fucking hear you fart.
- Probably.
One thing I learned about a tent
is that it's just not noise proof at all.
- No.
- You can hear
fucking everything.
Literally, I remember we were sleeping
and I could hear like the
other tent fucking farting
in the background.
And I'm just. "Okay, who was that?
Was that you Nabi?"
Okay. Whatever.
But like some of these tents
that these people bought,
they weren't fucking tents.
So some of our neighbors, right?
One lot's like two lots down from us.
They start unpacking this tent, right?
And then this tent has
fucking compartments, right?
And then not only that,
I remember walking past,
they had an entrance, right?
They had an entrance that
had lights on the entrance.
Okay?
- Like fairy lights.
- And this tent had like
two fucking bedrooms,
a living room.
- Oh, my parents
had a tent like that.
- Yeah.
- Is that even a tent, though?
- Yeah, it's like family tent.
- It's just a pop-up apartment.
- Yeah, but it's like a family tent.
- I'm just like this isn't
a tent, this is a 2LDK.
- Bro, those tents are a
fucking nightmare to set up.
- Yeah.
- They're a pain in the ass.
- Well, but that's the thing, right?
It's like I get it if it was a family,
but this was a couple.
- This was a couple.
- Yeah, that's ridiculous.
Well, it's 'cause you're a Japanese couple
so naturally, you're not
gonna in the same bed.
- Exactly.
- Of course.
- I was getting to that
because this like this tent
had carpet, had shelves and I'm just like,
might as well just bring a
fucking caravan at this point.
- I mean, we'd take that
but we stayed for like three weeks.
- That makes sense if it's three weeks.
- They stayed for a single
night and like okay-
- A single night?
- Yeah, a single night.
They came with us and
then left the same day.
- So here's the premium Japanese couple
experience that I saw, all right?
So we walked past this tent, right?
And of course this
Japanese couple, you know,
obviously very intimate Japanese couple
to be going on a camping
trip by themselves together.
- Very intimate.
So the peak Japanese couple experience
was seeing the guy next to his car
on a fucking gamer chair or something
and then seeing the girl on the other side
of this massive tent on a hammock,
both of them by themselves,
not interacting,
premium Japanese couple experience.
- I mean, isn't that love?
Knowing when to ignore each other.
- Yeah, that's love.
- No, I mean, I say it's
a premium Japanese couple
experience because the amount of times
like we've gone to like
onsens or ryokans or something
and like it's just like us, the boys,
and we're just surrounded
by Japanese couples.
- They don't talk to each other.
- Not talking to each other.
- Just not interacting with each other.
- Couples that social distance together,
stay together, you know?
They're just social distancing, you know?
But like one part I
couldn't fucking believe was
with wood-fire, right?
So you had to like go to, well, I mean,
they have the option to
go to like the reception,
quote unquote, where you
could buy pre-cut wood-fire.
- Yeah. That's normally how it is.
- [Joey] All right. Yeah.
- 'Cause they don't want you
to just fucking picking
shit up around the area
and burning it.
- Right,
but like the thing is-
- I mean, that's we did.
- That's what we did.
Because each bundle was like 500 yen.
Maybe for like a bundle about-
- I mean, it wasn't about the price.
- It wasn't about the price
because like this wood,
because it's like pre-cut
and clean and dry,
this thing burns through
like so fucking quickly
and I'm like we're here
for the entire day.
We want this fire to keep
going the entire day, right?
This thing is not gonna
last us the entire day.
So I just said, fuck it.
And I just like went out into the bush
and just grabbed some wood
and our friend Nabi had a hatchet
and I'm like, "Give me that shit,"
Just fucking started like
deforesting this fucking forest.
- Fucking die, (indistinct) forest.
- No, no, no, we wouldn't
deforest the forest.
They were already like-
- Bits of dead trees on the ground.
- Bits of dead trees on the ground
that we just cut up.
- I didn't cut down any trees.
(all laughing)
- Joey just starts his
fucking Animal Crossing
this fucking campsite.
- To emphasize, we
didn't cut up any trees.
We just cut off some branches
that had fallen down,
- Yeah, we cut the logs
into like sizeable pieces.
- Yeah and brought them to our campsite
because that to me is the
camping experience, right?
We're out in the wilderness with like-
- You're like out here in
like a fucking swimming pool
treating it like Bear Grylls.
(laughing)
- Well, that's the thing it's like,
- We wanted to make the most of it.
- We wanted to make the most of it,
because otherwise we would've had to spend
like a hundred bucks for firewood.
I'm like, fuck that.
- No, no, it's not about
the 100 bucks of firewood,
because it's just-
- It's not about the money, Joey!
It's about the experience!
- It's about the experience!
- Exactly!
The most amount of fun
going out into the bush,
picking up some like dead
trees and just bringing it back
and just chopping the shit out of it.
That was the most fun.
- I'd be so fucking bored if I turned up
and it's like I got like 10 neighbors,
I've got a power outlet.
- Yeah.
- Fuck man.
- And it's like, pre-packaged.
- Here you go. Here's
all the things you need.
Go have fun.
- All fucking micro-transactions
with your camping experience, man.
Probably like bring your food if you want.
I know some camping trips
actually bring you meat,
and a grill, if you want
to have food for that.
- I'm like just stay at a hotel.
- The best part about camping, right,
is when you all turn up, right,
and then you're one mate is
like, "Boys, I brought bacon."
And everyone's like, "Yes. Let's go!
- Exactly.
- He brought
fucking perishable foods.
What an idiot, but it works.
I mean, and in the UK,
there's a little place you
can just kinda ask them,
you're like "Hey, can
I camp on your land?"
They were like, "Yeah, sure."
- Yeah.
- Stuff like that.
There's a lot of places
where you can camp-
- I mean, in Australia there's
designated camping areas,
but like it's first come, first serve.
If it's full, then fuck
off somewhere else.
- Is there a place like that in Japan
or is it all regulated camping?
- It's all regulated.
- Ah, fuck.
- Yeah.
- I mean, it was fine for
the experience it was,
but I definitely prefer
the camping experience
I had in other countries
because it just kind of didn't
feel like camping, you know?
- I mean, there was that
other couple next to us
that brought a fucking TV.
- Oh yeah! (laughing)
- Honestly, I'd do it.
I'd do it too.
- And they're like playing Smash Bros
or whatever the fuck it was.
I'm like, just like, why
are you even camping, dude?
- I mean, if you've got a fucking plug,
why not bring the 50 inch TV?
- I guess so.
- Why not bring the 50 incher, bro?
- Yeah, I guess so.
It's ridiculous.
I was like, you think that these guys
have been like permanently living there
with how much shit they have.
- I mean, truthfully,
I tend to bring like,
'cause you can get
those like really shitty
like 19 inch battery powered monitors.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- You can bring that.
You can bring a Switch.
- The thing is,
because I've had a pretty
fucking stressful week
because of the whole move thing.
So it's just so nice to just sit down
and look at a fire for 12 hours
and literally drink
and talk about nothing.
It was the best fucking experience I had.
- That is the best part of it.
- Yeah.
- Wait, who set up the tents?
- We all did.
- We all did, yeah.
- Did you really, did you all?
Did you really?
- Yeah, we all did, we all did.
- Really, 'cause most of
the time it's "we all did"
and it's like I watched
the other guy do it.
- Our tents really
weren't that complicated.
- Really?
- 'Cause our tent
literally just like a triangle.
One of one of those fucking pyramid tents.
- It wasn't fucking inflatable apartment
- It wasn't a two bedroom apartment.
- I was like 15 I had
the ones where you like,
you fucking throw it
in the air and it psh.
- Yeah, like Nabi had
one of those as well.
- Pain in the ass to fold up though.
- Yeah.
Ours was a bit more complicated
and we still somehow fucked it up
because, so our tent was like,
it's like not pre, I mean,
it kinda is pre-built
but we kind of have to like
strengthen the supports,
the support beams that
it comes with, right?
- Yeah.
- Support beams.
- What they are called, the structure?
- Poles.
- Yeah, the poles, yeah.
The bone structure.
- I don't fucking know what it was.
- Poles, it's just fucking poles.
- It wasn't a pole
'cause it was like part
of the tent, right?
So this tent came with like support beams
that like supported the structure, right?
- It's all just fucking poles.
- It's baby mode, tent mode.
- Baby mode, tent mode.
We literally didn't have to do anything.
We just had to like fucking,
well, we thought we didn't
have to do anything, right?
Because it all kind of like
unfolded and we like put it up.
All we had to do was
like put the pegs down.
We thought great, job done.
We didn't know it was job done
because when we were trying to sleep,
when me and Joey were trying to sleep,
it just kept caving in, right?
(Connor laughing)
- Because it was also windy as fuck.
- It was a windy ass-
- It was insanely windy.
- It was a windy ass night
so like every like fucking hour,
I'd get woken up by
this tent just caving in
and I just have to like bring
the support pole up again.
I'm just like oh, for fucks sake.
- [Joey] It was horrible.
- And I could hear Joey
was like having trouble sleeping as well.
- I did not sleep at all that night.
- And it was only when we were packing up
that we took the cover off.
And I was just like, at the
top of the support beam,
there was this label that said, "Push."
I was like, oh, why does
this label say push?
And I push it down and I just hear click.
- And everything is like solid as fuck.
- It's like Transformers,
everything just clicked into place.
- I just hear this click and I was like,
"What was that click?"
And then I tried to like
push in the support beam-
- Did you not like read
like the manual or anything?
- No, no.
- Clearly, we should have.
(laughing)
- I mean, it was a tent.
- I'll just give it a
quick like gaze over.
- I'm not used to tents like that.
I'm used to the ones that you
have to like kind of connect
all the poles together
and do it yourself, right?
So I was like, oh cool.
- Who bought the tents?
- Oh, Nabi did.
- Oh, okay.
- So I was like, oh, I've
never seen this kind of tent,
but it seems easy enough.
It literally just pops out.
- Some reason whenever you
fucking do your friend's tent,
it's like the biggest piece of shit ever.
It's like your tent pristine, brand new.
While your friend's tent is
literally like falling apart.
The poles don't fucking
connect, they're rusty as fuck.
It's like what did you do to this tent?
How did you put it in this bad condition?
- I don't know.
- I don't know,
I always had that.
- Yeah, but like that night
it was so fucking windy.
I mean, the day before
it was so fucking raining
that we were just like
we're not camping out there.
It's like a torrential
thunderstorm out there.
- Yeah.
- So we're just gonna fucking,
we just went to like a nearby dyokon,
but the next day though, when
we actually went camping,
it was fucking great.
- Yeah.
It was a great experience.
- I remember Aki the next day,
Aki was like, "So what
did you guys talk about?"
And I just sat there and was like-
- It doesn't matter what you talked about.
- Fuck, what did I talk about?
- What's talked about in
camping, stays in camping.
- Exactly.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Don't ask us that.
- And it was clearly so unimportant
that it didn't even retain in my memory.
All I remember is, ooh, a fire burn.
That's all I remember
from that camping trip.
- Your caveman instincts come out.
- I remember trying to start
a fire for like a full hour.
'Cause Nabi bought these
flints and I'm just like,
"Guys, guys, we've got a
power outlet right there."
- He's like in a Bear Grylls-
- Just get a fucking outlet.
- And Endo, the entire
time was standing there
with a blowtorch and he's just like,
"Ready when you are, Garnt."
- Why does
he have a blow torch?
Why does he have a blow torch?
You making fucking creme
brulee on the campsite?
What's going on?
- So there's just me like huddled around
this fucking moss trying
to set that on fire.
And like, I try setting like so many,
like I try like getting
some YouTube tutorials out.
I tried this for like a full fucking hour.
- It just fucking torrential
rained the day before
so all the wood's gonna be wet and shit.
- And meanwhile I'm
just like sitting there
in my gamer chair just
playing FireStarter.
Come on, you got it, you got it, mate.
- Oh my God.
- I just wanted to play
Bear Grylls, man, I'm sorry.
- It was almost scary how
enthusiastic Garnt was
to start a fire.
He was just like, you know like,
because like we got there.
- You make it sound like I'm
a fucking casual arsonist.
- You are, Garnt, you are.
- We got there, right?
And we're like all right,
let's figure out what we're going to do.
Are we gonna set up a tent?
You know, blah, blah, blah.
All right, everybody help
get all the stuff out.
And Garnt's just kind
of standing there like,
"I just can't wait to start a fire."
That's how people become arsonists.
- Come on, come on, come on.
Let's not pretend that the
start of a camping trip
is always when you are able
to stop first start a fire.
- No, of course.
- That's how you know
the camping trip has begun, right?
- I knew from how enthusiastic you were,
- Garnt's like in the car
lighting stuff on fire.
- I knew from how enthusiastic
Garnt was to start the fire,
I was like, if I let
this man start a fire,
he's not gonna do anything else.
He's gonna stay next to that fire,
fueling that for bitch for like 12 hours.
- 'Cause who the fuck
enjoys building a tent?
Like nobody actually
enjoys building a tent.
It's fiddly as fuck.
Half the time you're trying to figure out
how the instruction manuals work.
Because the like-
- You mean the instruction
manual we didn't read?
- Exactly. Right.
'Cause it's a fucking pain in the ass.
You try and figure out like,
somehow they've picked the images
that make it like the least legible
and like the least
understandable to like figure out
how to build this tent.
- Man, it sounds like you took
the monkey brain on the trip.
I didn't need to come.
There was already monkey brain there.
- Garnt was very monkey
brain around that fire.
Like he was like (panting).
I feed it more.
- I was single-handedly fueling
that fire for like 12 hours.
This fire went on for like 12 hours
and I was the one like
fueling it every time.
- I didn't have to do anything.
I'm just like Garnt's
assistant right here,
just like fueling it.
- We need to look for like an actual place
where we can camp, like legit camp.
- Legit camp.
I don't know if we'll
be able to find that.
- No power outlets.
- I don't know
if we'll be able to find that in Japan.
- I'm sure we can find it.
- What was your camping
experience like in England?
- In England, I didn't go much in England.
I went around France mainly.
A lot of the time in France though,
like it was like campsites like that.
- Who'd you camp with?
- My family for the most part,
but then obviously, 'cause we're in Wales,
so it's really easy to
just camp for a weekend.
And normally you were just
like in a farmer's land
in like some fucking random field.
- Oh, like land that someone owns.
- Yeah.
- Oh.
- 'Cause they'd always know someone.
You could just be like, oh, can we camp?
And maybe it'd be like a tenner a night
because they didn't really want anything,
they were just like,
"Don't just leave a mess.
Just clean everything up."
- Oh, 'cause you can't
do that in Australia.
It needs to be in like national reserve.
- No, you can do whatever
you want on the land.
And normally you're right
next to woods and stuff
so obviously there's no
power outlets or anything
and probably a decent
walk away from the car
that you came in.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So yeah, it was just good fun though.
I mean, you just normally
just set up the tent.
If you can get fire going, go ahead,
but it might be raining a fuck ton
and you might have to start
drinking beers in the tent,
like four of you squished
in this tent like,
"How you guys doing?
All right, nice.
Someone wanna boil the kettle?
We'll get some pot noodles going."
Whatever you do.
We did like a Duke of
Edinburgh as well. We did that.
- Oh yeah.
- That was good fun as well.
- Yeah, because in Japan,
you can't even like put
a fire on the ground.
- Yeah, you need to buy like a fire pit.
- Well, 'cause sometimes in some places
you have to clean it up yourself
and it was easier to just bring something
that you could wrap like all the ash in.
- Right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Which is like, I think
we did that a few times.
'Cause if you have to clean it up,
sometimes it's an absolute pain in the ass
getting rid of all this ash.
- Well, because in Australia
all you did was just dig a hole.
And then once you were done with the ash,
you just fill up that hole again.
- I mean, it's good for the land
but I mean, sometimes you
can't do that in some places.
- [Joey] Ah, true, true, true.
- Yeah. I mean, it's whatever.
I just kinda like, it was never
more than like two nights.
It was always like a night.
Put the tent up.
Kind of get drunk.
- Yeah.
- Eat a lot of bacon in the
morning, bacon sandwiches.
Then just fuck off.
- Yeah, two nights I feel is
like the optimal camping time.
- Yeah, I'd say so.
Two nights is about right before-
- It depends, 'cause you need
something to do the second day
because the first night,
you're setting up,
you're having a few drinks.
What do you do during the whole second day
before you start drinking?
You can't immediately
like start drinking beers
at like 11.
- I mean, that's what we did.
- That's kind of what we did.
- I mean, I guess you can,
but then there's someone
like driving, right?
Oh, I don't know.
I mean, I kind of want to do something.
I don't know.
- Yeah, well that's when
you can bring the TV
and connect it to the power outlet.
It's like who's got the Switch?
- Well, 'cause if you go
camping with British people,
you know, and there's like four of you,
like a 24 pack, sorry,
I smashed so much there,
a 24 pack won't last more
than a night of beers,
you know what I mean?
- That's true. Yeah.
- So it's like how much
beer are you bringing along
for this thing, right?
You can't do day drinking.
You need like 40 beers at least
for that whole experience.
But I mean, that's why
I like doing something.
That's why like-
- Well, I mean, we brought
like a pack of cards
and like, you know, that kind of stuff.
I mean, we never cracked them opened.
(Connor laughing)
- We just left them there
for like decoration.
- I was just having too much
fucking fun with the fire.
(all laughing)
- He's like way too
enthusiastic about the fire.
- Was this fire burning like 24/7?
- Yeah. Well not 24/7.
- It was burning or like
a good like 14 hours.
- Jesus Christ, God, you monkey.
- Because we fucking adventured
out and got all the wood.
Right?
- That was half the fun.
- So what did you do the second day?
You said you slept in
the tent the first night.
- No, no, no, we didn't sleep
in a tent the first night
because we got there like
super, super early on
the second day because-
- The first day it was raining like crazy.
- Yeah, the first day we
missed the day of camping.
So we did what anyone do and
just had a nice day at an onsen
and slept with a nice roof over our heads.
And then we just went there the second day
and we just basically
stayed there all day.
- Yeah, We got there like
9:00 a.m. or something.
Like super early in the morning
so it was like a full, full day.
- Because I was in the area near you
and the storm was fucking brutal.
- Oh yeah.
I mean, the storm in
Tokyo was brutal as well.
- Yeah.
- Was it? I don't know.
I was kayaking and then I was
on like the ocean kayaking
and then the guy who was with us
was like, "Oh, there's a storm coming."
And I was like, "Yeah,
I can fucking hear it."
Like (imitating rumbling)
like rumbling everywhere.
- Yeah.
- And then suddenly
I'm just like kayaking,
just chilling, you know, nice weather.
And then suddenly out of nowhere,
like torrential rains starts pouring down,
just will not stop.
It's fucking freezing as well, man.
It was like, I literally felt like
I was at the "Shawshank Redemption"
when he's crawling
through the tunnel of shit
with the rain, it was like that bad.
And I'm like I feel like I'm
crawling through the shit
trying to get back to shore
because I'm freezing right now.
And I'm fucking like, "Ah!"
Wish I was camping instead at that point.
But it was really good fuck
kayaking until that started.
- Oh, yeah.
- Good fun.
- God, I haven't been kayaking,
I've never been kayaking
in the ocean I don't think.
I've been kayaking on
like rivers and lakes
and stuff like that,
but I don't think I've ever
been kayaking in the ocean.
- It's good fun, it's chill.
- It seems a lot scarier.
- Nah.
- Something about the ocean
just scares me. You know?
(Connor laughing)
No, I mean, the ocean
is just scary, right?
It's a scary place.
- Normally, a lot of
these things, you know,
unless you own your own kayak and stuff,
you can't just go and do it.
If you're renting,
there's normally always a
guy that comes with you.
- Oh yeah.
- To make sure you don't fucking drown.
- But if it's a lake, like
you know, fucking whatever.
- 'Cause I was like in a group
with a bunch of Japanese people
and like one of them just like capsized.
I'm like, how the fuck
did you manage that?
- Probably did it on purpose.
- He just flipped his boat
and was just like in
the middle of the ocean.
I'm like, how the fuck's
he gonna get back here?
(all laughing)
He got back in somehow, but my God,
that man must have been freezing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I had like my phone on me as well.
I was like, I'm not capsizing.
- Yeah, fuck that.
- You put your phone on you
on a kayaking trip in
the middle of the ocean.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I sent you a picture of the snake.
- Oh, that was on the ocean.
- So I was like going, we
were kayaking past like rocks
and I was doing this kind of thing
where you could kayak around like rocks
and like you go through like
caves and stuff, kayaking.
And there was just this like
fucking snake just chilling,
like some kind of like,
this is like the entrance to death.
And I was like fuck, let me
me get a quick 4k pic of that.
Whipped out my phone
and started taking pics.
- (indistinct) in 4k.
- Yeah. (laughing)
For the fucking snake.
Yeah. It was good fun.
But yeah, I wish I could
go camping with you guys.
- Well, I mean, yeah, we
definitely want to go.
I mean, Garnt and I still
have all the stuff with us
so we definitely want to do that again.
- You gonna get a driving
license now, Garnt?
- Yeah, honestly, this camping trip
single-handedly convinced
me to get a driving license
'cause just like the
drive to this camp site
was fucking beautiful.
We were driving up these mountains.
- The weather was perfect.
- Dude, the moment you leave Tokyo,
the views get like insane.
- Yeah, 100%.
- So it's like you always
want to drive in Japan
'cause you're like, I can't
wait to see the views.
All of the service stations are amazing.
Like the food you can get
at the service stations here are insane.
Like when you stop at the
service stations in the UK,
I don't know about America,
like on like motorways or what
are they called in the US?
- Highways.
You know, when you stop at them to break,
it's like what?
Like McDonald's, KFC, it's
like I don't wanna stop.
When you stop in Japan,
it's like you can get like-
- Oh, the services areas, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You get like ramen, curry,
sushi, all like fresh as fuck.
And it's so good and it's like,
well, of course I want to stop
because I want to get my coffee-
- The one we stopped at had
like a full on like fucking,
it was like a mall.
- Yeah, it was nuts.
- At the service area.
- And you get really good fucking food.
- 'Cause like sushi, ramen, all that,
that's just fast food here, right?
- It's crazy.
It's such good quality as well.
I'm out here at night and
there's like a Yoshinoya
at the service station.
I'm like, it's 10:00 a.m.
I'm gonna have a Yoshinoya
beef roll, let's go.
- Yeah, the one we stopped at
had like a like fucking
Starbucks and like-
- Oh, yeah.
- It had like a whole,
it was like almost like
an anime shop. wasn't it?
That was selling like
anime goods randomly.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, they were
selling like "Initial D" merch.
- Ah man, it's so good.
You stop, you get that fat meal,
you grab that coffee,
you start playing the music on the car,
just literally driving
with the Mount Fuji view,
clear as day.
Fuck you, Chris. It's great.
You can't beat it.
- Yeah, we got an insane view
of Fuji during the day, yeah.
- 'Cause that's the
thing about Japan, right?
Like everything here is so aesthetic.
I mean, like even looking
at Mount Fuji, right?
You look at Mount Fuji
and I'm just like, man,
God really pat himself on the
back when he made that, man.
Like Jesus Christ, like Mount Fuji-
- He's like my finest work.
- Mount Fuji, like you talk
about Mount Everest or whatever,
being like the highest
mountains or something.
Fuji is like the most photogenic mountain.
- It is the most
picturesque mountain. 100%.
- It's like the best spot as well.
- Yeah.
- It's so good, man.
And then like everyone's so
nice driving on the expressways
and stuff here and like the roads,
like it's so chill.
- It's pretty hard to find like
an asshole driver in Japan.
- Yeah. Everyone's so nice.
I was like, no, no, you go ahead.
Everyone's really nice. You know?
It's super chill driving.
It's like driving easy mode
and you get like all the best,
it's just great.
- Everything's baby mode here, man.
- So now Garnt, you've
got to go through the hell
of getting your license changed-
- Yeah, that's the thing,
like I didn't have a reason to drive
or to want to drive and now I do.
- And the quicker you get it as well
you can get rid of those rookie things
that they have on-
- Rookie things?
- Oh, like the stickers.
- Yeah, for the first year
when you get your license,
even though you've driven
in other countries,
you have to get these rookie stickers
on your front and back.
- It's like a provisional kind of sticker.
- Yeah, I don't like it.
(Garnt laughing)
It was a pain having to
remember them all the time,
bringing them along with you.
You're like, "Oh, sorry,
gotta bring my stickers.
I gotta put them on."
Sorry I interrupted you, you were saying.
- I can't remember what I was saying,
but I guess the only
thing I remember is like,
I am not looking forward
to doing more paperwork,
which is what I'm gonna be
doing a lot of this year.
- Japan is like the never
in cesspool of paperwork.
- Get the paperwork done
when it's not stressful.
So that when you-
- That doesn't happen.
- No, no.
- That's a trick question.
- If you got shit happening, you're busy,
the last thing you want
to do is lose a day.
Like if you have the time to lose a day,
do it now when you can, right?
Like that's why I did it.
- Bold of you to assume that
we just have a day to lose.
- I don't have a day, but
I had a day where like,
it wasn't that bad if I lost it
'cause like you know,
when I eventually move
at the end of the year, you know,
it's gonna be fucking hell.
- Yeah.
- And I'm not gonna want to lose a day.
(Joey laughing)
- It's gonna be more than a day, trust me.
- Get it now, Garnt.
- It's not about losing a day.
It's about losing a day to paperwork.
- It's never gonna be good
so just fucking do it.
- I know, I mean, it's just finding,
it's not even the motivation,
but just like every time I wake up,
I'm just like maybe today's a
day and today's never the day.
- There's like a Denny's
near the place as well
so you should be fine.
There's like a Coco's diner.
- Yeah, exactly.
This episode is sponsored by Gamer Supps.
- One word, gamers.
Two words, Gamer Supps.
(laughing)
Four words, Gamer Supps waifu cups.
That's right.
- Let's go.
- Bars! (laughing)
- Gamer Supps is a healthier
and more cost-effective
alternative to soda or sugary drinks.
Every waifu cups, as you could see here
we and the boys are
rocking our waifu cups,
comes with a free sample of Gamer Supps.
That's right here, holding
it in Garnt's hand.
Designed to be the perfect gaming drink
and it'll help you stay
awake for an anime binge
because I can't stay awake
without my Gamer Supps
injected in my veins.
(Garnt screaming)
- And gentlemen, here's the best part.
If you guys support us,
then you never know.
We might get our own flavor
of Gamer Supps down the road.
- Hell yeah.
- Let us know what flavor
we should make if we get the chance.
As you gentlemen will now see,
I've added my Gamer
Supps to my gamer drink
and now the boobs will take
the color as I'm being told.
And it looks delightful.
- The Gamer Supps taste great,
are much healthier than energy drinks,
only cost 35 cents per serving,
but they're going fast.
- What are you waiting
for? Get your Gamer Supps.
Come on. What are you waiting for?
Get your waifu cups. What are you doing?
Come on!
- That's right!
What are you waiting for?
Buy some waifu cups, buy some waifu shirts
and buy some waifu candy at gamersupps.com
and use code trashtaste.
- The more you buy, the
quicker you can get your waifu,
so what are you waiting for?
Go get your Gamer Supps waifu cups, bars.
- I'll see you guys at the checkout.
- Back to the episode.
- Speaking of leisurely activities,
you guys went snowboarding-
- Ages ago.
- Ages ago, yeah, yeah.
- I don't think we talked
about that on the podcast yet.
- I don't think we have, no, it was my-
- 'Cause I couldn't go to that one.
- Yeah. It was my very first
experience snowboarding.
- Hmm. How was that?
- It was, so obviously I went before,
like we remembered that the reason
I wanted to try out
snowboarding was purely
because of SSX Tricky and
Snowboard Kids on the N64,
but yeah, had the choice
between going snowboarding
and going skiing and I'm
just like 100% snowboarding.
- I want that SSX Tricky.
- Because everyone told me
that it's like way harder
to start snowboarding.
Like beginners find it easier to ski,
but it's like harder to master,
whereas snowboarding
is harder to get into,
but it's easier to master
from what I've heard.
- Roughly.
- I think that's true. Yeah.
- Yeah, and I guess like,
so my first experience
snowboarding was that, it was okay,
I didn't realize how
much I took for granted
friction in my life.
Okay.
(laughing)
- How so, Garnt, how so?
- How so?
- Like I remember the first time,
so we got all dressed up.
I put on all the kits and everything.
Put on the snowboards on
like one shoe or one foot
or however you lock yourself in.
And then, so my first mission was to walk
from where I put my
snowboard on to the ski lift.
And I remember trying
to take my first step,
immediately slip, and I was just like,
this is a bit of a challenge, innit?
(all laughing)
Wait, so you're telling me
I'm gonna have to go down a fucking hill
when I can't even take a single step?
- Because it's the type of movement
you'd never do otherwise, right?
- It's so unnatural. Right?
And so I fucking waddled my
way over to the ski lift.
- Did you have your snowboard on
or is it like you're
carrying your snowboard.
- No, I had my snowboard on,
- I think you had the one boot in, right?
- [Connor] Oh, you had the one boot in?
- Yeah, I had the one boot in
'cause we walked over to like-
- Kind of hobbling like that.
- Yeah, we walked over
to the beginner ski lift
and I was with Sydney and
Meilyne, and Meilyne's partner
and-
- Meilyne wasn't having
a good time either.
- Yeah, Meilyne wasn't
having a good time either.
So only one of us knew how to snowboard.
And so only one of us was like
showing us how it was done.
And Meilyne knows how to ski,
but this was her first
time trying to snowboard
either as well.
So at least I hadn't like a
fellow novice with me, right?
(all laughing)
- I'm not the only one.
And so we walked all
over to this ski lift.
Right?
And so to go through the gates,
we have to like scan ourselves in, right?
And like the problem with
having this big snowboard on you
is that once I start like taking a step,
sometimes I don't know how to stop, right?
(Connor laughing)
So there was this fucking
kid in front of me, right?
There was this kid,
fucking pro snowboarder,
like easily goes through the gate.
I like go through the
gate, take my first step
and I swear to God, I
almost fall on this kid.
(laughing)
- You almost took a kid out?
- Yeah, I almost took out
this fucking five year old
in front of me.
- Frankly, had it coming.
Had it coming.
- Luckily Mackey just like grabbed me
before I fell on this kid.
I was like...
At this point I hadn't
even got onto the ski lift.
And so-
- That's the first step.
- Yeah, 'cause I think I was on my way
and I was texting, "How's it going?
How's it going?"
He's like, "It's hard.
It's really hard."
- It's hard.
- It's fucking hard.
- It's really...
- [Meilyne] And I just saw your head, wee.
- Wait, when was that?
- [Meilyne] When you
went down by yourself.
- Oh yeah. I tumbled a lot of times.
We'll get to that.
- It's really difficult to
fall face first with skis.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause how the fuck
are you gonna do that?
Snowboarding's very easy.
- Oh yeah. Yeah.
It's almost guaranteed you're gonna fall
face first on a snowboard.
- Carry on, carry on,
tell us about your story.
- Okay, so,
I waddle my way to the ski lift.
And I've never, obviously
this is my first time
on a ski lift.
I've never like, I don't know
what the right technique is
or like how to like,
(Joey laughing)
'cause you don't think
about this thing, right?
You think, walking, easy.
One foot forward, next foot forward.
It was like I was a baby
trying to figure out how to walk again.
So it's taking like
all of my mental energy
just to figure out how to stay on two feet
and then so the person tells me
to like go to this point here
where the ski lift is going
to go and like take you up.
And I'm just thinking, this is like,
I've never like panicked
before trying to figure out
how to waddle literally one meter forward.
- Yeah, it was pretty bit mean of him
to make you get on a fucking
ski lift first thing.
You should've just gone,
like walked up the hill
a little bit and just tried to go down.
- Or at least get on the ski lift
holding your snowboard, right?
- Yeah.
- Can you do that?
- Yeah, you can do that.
- Yes, you can do that.
Yeah, but clearly no one told
you that you could do that.
- Maybe (indistinct) was
like nah, trial by fire
will be the option I think.
- Okay, yeah, I literally
didn't know that was an option.
- Normally, yeah, you are suppose to,
with beginners on snowboard,
what you make them do is
you just kind of make them walk up a hill,
like a very, very, like not steep hill.
And just kind of make them
like go down straight,
like horizontal or perpendicular,
sorry, to the slope.
But that was very much, wow. Okay.
- Mike is like fuck that,
on the ski lift right now.
- So I was kinda like a
animal looking over the edge
being like, okay, gotta go, gotta go.
No, don't want to go.
Okay, let's go now.
And so I'm like, I say a waddle,
this was like me trying
to fucking ice skate over
to like one meter ahead of
me and just stay still enough
for the ski lift to like
lift my butt up and go up.
So managed to do that luckily
without any big massive incidents-
- But then comes the next step.
- But then.
(all laughing)
- How do you get down?
- How do you get off it?
- I was having a great time.
I was like, okay, you know what,
this fucking slaps.
Look at this view.
Look at this, like I'm
having a great fucking time.
It's like being on a rollercoaster.
You know, when you're going up,
and you're just enjoying
the view, it's peaceful.
I'm just like, okay, I
can get into snowboarding.
- I can get into snowboarding.
- I can get into snowboarding
This is pretty cool.
And then I see where the exit is
and it gets closer and closer
and then it slowly dawns on me.
- How do I get off?
- I need to get off this.
- How do I exit this seat
that I'm currently sitting on right now?
And I see the kid in front of me gets off
no problem at all.
And I'm just like, oh, that looks easy.
That looks easy.
I just, you know, I just use the momentum
that the seat is carrying me through
and I just get off and
just slide off, right?
And I'm just like, cool.
I'm like shadow boxing, right?
'Cause I'm just like
visualizing this in my head.
I'm just like, how hard
can this possibly be?
- Right.
- Like how hard can this possibly be?
- This is like Garnt in the
shower, psyching yourself up.
- I was literally psyching myself up.
And I was just like, sure, I can do that.
Like if a five-year-old kid
can do it, then I can do it.
And so literally the first
thing that happens is
the lift goes up, it starts slowing down.
I'm like brilliant.
I'm not even gonna need
to do this at full speed.
It's going up like-
- They're gonna launch you off.
- I had no idea. Right?
I thought you just had to
use the momentum to ski off.
I had no fucking clue.
But honestly I think I
would have preferred that
because now I had zero
momentum and I'm just like,
shit, how do I position my feet?
Right?
And by the time I get to the
point where I need to get off,
I hadn't figured out
how I was gonna do this.
So literally the first
thing that happens is
I put both feet down.
I literally tried to-
- Horizontal?
- Huh?
- Like that?
- Yeah. Like that.
(laughing)
So I was just like, I was like, okay.
- First mistake.
- I was like okay, what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna put both feet down,
twist and they put one of my foot-
- Oh no.
- On the snowboard and just lightly
and just breezily just like slide down.
So that, so obviously
that didn't work out.
First, what I did was I
put first two feet down,
stood up immediate face plant.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, because there's
this thing behind you
that's pushing you forward
so you're just gonna go boop.
- Yeah, you gotta like
shimmy to the side like this,
- Yeah, you gotta shimmy like that
and then kind of go down like that.
- It would be nice if
someone was there to teach me
how it's done.
- I would not have done that to you,
Garnt, if I was there.
I would have told you how to have done it.
- But, the thing is,
here's the thing, right?
We apparently went on the
beginner slope, right?
(all laughing)
- The biggest lie.
- Yeah.
There was no way that this was
the fucking beginning slope.
And we found out afterwards
on the second day,
'cause me and Meilyne,
we weren't having a great time
trying to get down this beginner slope
and apparently we found on the next day
that there was a slope that was dedicated
to like people's first
time trying snowboarding.
No, we didn't go on that one.
We went on the fucking beginner slope,
which was people who had
already been experienced enough
to go down hills.
- Right, right.
- And so it was me
Meilyne, Sydney, and Mackey
at the top of this hill.
Mackey just fucking bolts
it down already. Right?
- Yeah.
- He was screaming at us.
"You guys are cowards!"
(all laughing)
- Yo, that guy was really fucking funny.
He was getting like
legitimately frustrated
they were like bad.
- Yeah.
- Just get good, just get good.
- He was like, "What do you mean?
Just go down, just go down.
Just go straight.
It's not hard."
(laughing)
- And a Mackey goes down first
and tries to like go the
rest of us into going down.
I'm just like, you know what guys?
I'm just gonna go.
I'm gonna do a pro gamer move
and I'm just gonna go down.
Immediately start tumbling fucking down.
(all laughing)
Like I must have like front flipped
five fucking times going down-
- Sounds like fucking "Looney Tunes."
(all laughing)
- And I'm just like, ah, damn,
in my mind, I thought snow
is gonna cushion the fall.
And I'm just like, man,
this hurts way more
than I thought it was going to do.
- It does cushion but like 30%.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because all of the snow
that you're snowboarding on
has been like plowed so it's compacted.
- Like jumping off your bed
onto a very flat pillow.
It's like it'll cushion
you, but to what extent?
- I'm just like, I had
this image in my mind
that it's just like oh-
- I'm just gonna tumble in!
- It's just like falling on clouds.
And I remember, because of that,
like when I first went down,
I did not hold back as well.
I just like fucking went as fast as I can
not realizing that-
- Jesus Christ.
- Not realizing that I
didn't know how to break.
(laughing)
And so quickly I kind of,
before I learned how to break,
I quickly realized that
the easiest way to break
was just the fall down.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
I mean, that's what they
teach you at first, right?
Is like to fall down probably.
- There's a reason why
like if you start young,
particularly in skiing and snowboarding,
you're going to be really fucking like,
you're gonna be so much
better than somebody
who learned later on just
because like when you're a kid
you're fearless.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Kids don't fucking know danger.
- No.
- When I was a kid,
I was going way too fast
and I would just go straight down
'cause I was fucking stupid
and that's what like,
I was just like, this is fun.
I love going like 100 miles per hour.
This is a good idea.
- Yeah.
- That's how people die.
- There's no danger here.
But when you're an adult
it's a little harder,
like yeah, because you fall over once
and you're like, holy shit, this hurts!
- Yeah, I'm not doing
that again. Fuck that!
- And so Meilyne and Sydney see me
fucking tumbling down this hill.
And then I look up and Mackey's like,
"All right, your turn now."
And they're just like, "No.
No, I don't think I will."
And so they start like
getting on their butts
and just like-
- Sliding down.
- And just like slowly sliding down
and Mackey's like, "No, come on guys,
come on, get up!
- Just be good!
Not just slide.
- Obviously 'cause I learned
young and I was very fortunate,
very lucky, very privileged
to be able to learn
how to ski and snowboard at a young age.
The one thing that kind of like,
I don't mind doing it
because I'd rather go
with my friends than not
but like it does suck having
to wait like 30, 40 minutes.
You go down a slope, it
takes you 30 seconds,
you gotta wait 40 minutes for
your friends to come down.
And then you're like, "Right.
Let's go on the beginner one, again.
Let's do it again."
- So Meilyne and Sydney
are literally psyching
themselves up on this hill
for like a good, like
40 minutes to an hour.
Right, Meilyne?
They were on this beginner hill.
- It's like this.
- Oh, okay.
'Cause I was imaging like.
- No, no, it was like that like that,
- Oh fuck off, no it wasn't.
- It was like that.
- It might have felt like that,
but it was probably like that.
- Okay, al I knew was that
I stood up for a second
and I started going way faster
than I was comfortable with.
(Joey laughing)
- That's called a hill.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, 'cause at the
ski resort we were at,
one of the, like the black diamond,
one of them was like only 30 degrees.
- Oh, that's not even that bad.
- Yeah, it wasn't, which is like.
- Which is like that.
- It's like nothing.
- So realistically, it was
probably like five degrees.
- It was, okay, I get it.
Because you can go pretty fast.
- It feels like,
especially when you're not used to that.
- When you can see the bottom,
it looks way worse than it is.
- Yeah, 100%, 100%.
- Anyway, go on.
- I don't know, man.
(Joey laughing)
- Well, I'll give you
the benefit of the doubt.
- It was the first time
for you so I get it.
- The beginning of the
hill was like quite steep,
but then you go around to the middle part,
which is the actual,
which I feel was the actual
beginner slope, right?
'Cause this hill obviously
wasn't even in like,
what's the word I'm looking for?
- Altitude?
- Slope.
- Slope angle.
- Gradient, gradient.
That's it, it wasn't equal in gradient.
So the best part to learn
on this beginner hill
was like right in like
the middle of this course.
- Oh, is this the part where he went
like in like around like that,
like did like a loop de loop.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So the best part to learn was
actually in the middle part,
which is how I learned how
to like control my speed-
- And turn?
- Yeah, and turn because
going down this hill
for the first time I had two
speeds, it was go and tumble.
(guys laughing)
That was the two speeds that I had.
So, while waiting for Sydney and Meilyne
went on YouTube and started
like looking at some tutorials.
- How to snowboard.
- On the slope.
- Yeah, on the slope of how to snowboard.
- I wanted to be that guy
who like slides past you
and I'm just like, what's this guy doing?
Oh, oh.
(laughing)
- Yeah, because the thing about Mackey
is that he's a good snowboarder,
but I don't think he knows how
to explain how to snowboard.
'Cause I was asking Mackey ,
"Mackey , What's the like
the right technique?"
- Yeah, he's very much
like, "Oh, just do it.
- [Joey] Just go, just go.
- He's very much, "Oh you just
go like this and like this,
and then you just..."
You know that clip of like
that Australian surfer
or not Australia, but just that surfer
who's just like, and it goes
(imitates engine roaring),
(Joey speaking indistinctly)
Yeah, that's kind of why I heard,
when Mackey was trying to
explain to me how to snowboard.
It was just like, "Oh,
you just go like this
and then you turn like this
and then you control
your speed like this."
And I'm just like, "Mackey ,
you're just like showing me
like different angles here.
This means nothing to me"
- It sucks 'cause it's
like you have to learn
to like put your body in the place
where your body doesn't
want to naturally be.
- Right, because you have
to put all your weight
in your front foot,
which means you're gonna
be leaning into the hill.
- Yeah, you lean into it
which you don't wanna do.
- Just naturally, you don't do that.
- Yeah, and then you
gotta like throw your body
from side to side with your back leg
and it's like-
- It is a weird move.
- If you haven't done it before,
it feels really unnatural,
like initially 'cause it's like whoa.
- Yeah, and that's why the first time,
like after you finished the next day,
oh, you fucking feel that
because you're using all these muscles
you've never used before.
- Yeah, we actually had
the snowboarding trip
for like two days, but
I could only go one day.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
'Cause the second day
you're fucked, right?
- Oh, I had never felt
more fucked in my life.
- [Joey] Yeah, I feel that, yeah.
- On this like beginner slope,
I don't know which fucking
sick fuck decided to do this,
but I was like, that's
funny, but also my God.
On this beginner slope, right?
It's like this very narrow kind of
like a hill going down, like winding.
Right?
- Yeah.
- And at the bottom of
this wind, the exit to it
someone had put poles like a big X,
but it was open, right?
So you could go on it,
but the only way that you
could avoid these poles
was to jump over them in the middle.
- Or go under them, right?
- Or go under them, which
you weren't gonna do
'cause the gap to jump over was
like this, which isn't much,
but when you're a beginner or
even if you're experienced-
- Your board is not coming off the snow.
- It's hard to get, if
you're not experienced
doing any kind of jump on a snowboard,
lifting your board up for a
considerable amount of time
is unnatural and hard to do.
- They're heavy as well.
- Yeah, it's heavy. It's like this, right?
So there's no way you'll
get, maybe like this, right?
- Yeah, it was like that.
- Off the ground.
And so I was like, all right,
"Just jump over it, Garnt."
So I went, I jumped over it
and my board like just
clipped it a little bit.
And I was like, oh shit.
I turn around, Garnt fucking jumps,
just fucking jumps.
(all laughing)
Face plants.
And I was like I knew it was gonna happen,
but it was funny.
- This late in the day.
When I was like, I was like starting-
- He was getting the hang of it.
- I was like starting to
get the feel of this right?
And you know, I went with
the philosophy of just like,
I'm just gonna fall down
and hopefully I'll learn something new
every time I fall down.
- Trial by fire, right?
- Yeah.
Like there's only so many
ways you can fall down
before you figure out a way
to not fall down, right?
- Of course.
- And so I remember seeing,
like I remember seeing these crosses
in the middle of like this course
that I was going down with Connor.
And I was like, I fell down before
and I was like, "Connor, what do we do?
Why do they have these here?"
- What is this?
- Yeah, what is this?
- And they're like, "I don't know.
Just fucking jump over
or go under it, right?"
- Just jump over. (laughing)
- 'Cause like there were two options.
You can either like jump over it
or you can like crouch super
low and just go under it.
Right?
- Yeah.
- It was it's like, you
couldn't really crouch under.
- Yeah.
- You'd have to like
lift them up and stop.
I don't know why they were there.
No one explained why they were there.
that they shouldn't have been
there, I'm not really sure.
- I guess someone just
forgot to put it away.
- I think so, it was pretty weird,
but I was like sick, free jump test.
Let's do it.
- So I was like, by the time
me and Connor were going down,
I was getting confident with myself.
I was like going a bit
faster than I was before.
You know, just limit testing myself.
And just as I did like
this fucking sick turn,
I was like, "Fuck yes."
- It was a pretty good
turn, it was a good turn.
- Yeah, I did I think the first clean turn
of my trip down front.
- Going front to like back.
- Yeah, and like I
heard Connor being like,
"Oh dude, fuck yeah, that was clean."
I was like, "Fuck yeah."
And then I see this X coming up,
this pole coming up and I'm just like,
"All right, pro gamer time.
I'm gonna attempt a pro gamer move.
- Let me unlock 100%
of my brain right now.
- Yeah, I saw Connor do
it and I just had to,
I saw Connor do it and I was
just like you know that scene
in the "Matrix" where
Morpheus just goes back to Neo
and is just like, "All you
need to do is believe."
(all laughing)
It's the jump test.
And I'm just like, "Oh, okay,
Morpheus. I can do this."
- Yeah.
- Then I get close,
like immediately realize
I've jumped way too late.
(laughing)
- He just jumped into it.
- Instead of like even jumping over it.
I just fucking jumped straight into it.
- Just face-planted, it was so good.
'Cause I was basically
just following Garnt
with my face backwards,
he must've been so creeped out.
I was just like going backwards
down the slope like this watching him.
Just checking, make
sure what he was doing.
And then actually watched him go into it.
It was so fucking funny.
- Oh, man.
- I got Mackey back.
I took Mackey down like this
slope that was ridiculous.
I was like, oh, 'cause they
all stopped and Meilyne quit.
And I was like, "All right,
Mackey , let's go down."
- For the record, Meilyne and Sydney quit
'cause they're weak.
- [Meilyne] You were
the first one to quit.
- No! Meilyne, no I wasn't!
- Meilyne came back the second day
and was like, "I'm returning, guys."
It was like "Lord of the Rings."
He came back finally.
Meilyne did like one slope and was like,
"I'm done, guys."
And then left.
- No, 'cause Meilyne,
she also had the choice to
snowboard or ski, right?
And after about like one attempt
going down this beginning
of slope on the snowboard,
she quits and just tries skiing again.
- And then quit 'cause she was shit at it.
- 'Cause she couldn't do it.
(all laughing)
Skiing is easy, right guys?
- She was like, "I know how to do it."
Couldn't do it.
(all laughing)
- [Meilyne] I just
don't have the strength.
(all laughing)
- Oh, yeah, that's what they
say, that's what they all say.
- So you couldn't do it.
- If only you had the skis
that first time around.
- Yeah.
- It's like, yeah, I can do it.
- Yeah, easy.
- I'm just holding back.
- Yeah.
I didn't wanna show off, you know?
And then Meilyne came back the next day
and was like guys,
'cause she only did like
two slopes on the first day.
She was like, "All right,
I'm gonna come back
and do snowboarding again.
I'm ready to try it.
I can do it.
Did like one thing and then gave up.
But at least she did
try again a second time.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So I was impressed.
- I did try again the second day actually
because I remember so I went
like all out on the first day.
Right?
'Cause I remember I didn't-
- You were fucked.
- I was fucked.
I didn't realize how tired I was
because we went down the
slope like a bunch of times.
I was there all day.
- Yeah.
- Took a lot of tumbles on the first day.
- As you do.
- And I was so ready for the second day
'cause I'm just like, by
the end of the first day,
I was just at the point
when I was getting the hang of it, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- So I was like, fuck
yes, day two. Let's go.
I opened my eyes on day two
and I felt like I fucking
got punched by Mike Tyson
or something like that, right?
Like I didn't realize
that the thing that hurt
the most was my neck.
- Oh yeah.
- 'Cause you've been
hitting your neck a bunch.
- Yeah, yeah.
- From the whiplash probably.
- Yeah, I didn't realize
that whiplash was a thing
when you tumble that much
but now I know that whiplash
is definitely a thing.
- You should have got a helmet as well.
They didn't give you one.
- Oh, you weren't wearing helmets?
- They didn't give him
one for some reason.
- Oh. that's fucking dangerous.
Jesus Christ.
- They didn't give us helmets
I don't think.
- Yeah, when I saw them without helmets,
I was like, this is a terrible idea.
(all laughing)
I could go a whole day without a helmet,
but like if I was doing like hard stuff,
I would be very like, I would not go down
the hard ones that I went down.
- I mean, if I went again,
'cause last time I went
snowboarding was like fuck,
like six years ago, I would
definitely get a helmet
just 'cause like my body's not used to it.
- I didn't really give a shit
'cause I was with these guys
on like the green slopes
and blue slopes and I was
like, ah, fuck it, it's fine.
But then like if I went down, like I took-
- If you went down to
like a black diamond-
- Well, yeah, so I took
Mackey down a black diamond.
I was like, oh, okay.
So everyone had left
and then it was Mackey
was the one calling them a coward.
And I was like, "All right, it's time.
Let's go and it's going to do a real one."
And there's a double black
diamond, which I wanted to do.
- [Joey] To clarify like black diamond
is like the hardest type of course.
- [Connor] It's just
like double black diamond
was just like the most extreme.
- Yeah.
- And I couldn't convince
him to do that 'cause I
think he was like, "Oh, no,
I'm good, but I'm not like that."
I was like, all right, okay.
- I love how something about snowboarding
just just turns every guy into a dude bro.
You know what I mean?
Like I can just imagine like
when Garnt did that clean turn
and Connor was like, "Yo!"
(all laughing)
- I was proud.
- Like what is it about it
that turns you into a lad?
- Because you want your boys to enjoy it
so that you can come back again.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like when I'm bringing my friends,
my biggest worry is that they will hate it
from falling over too much
and they don't want to do it again.
- Yeah.
- Because then I'm like I
can't bring my friends again.
Like, we can't go to the Alps. You know?
We can't go to Italy, drink espressos,
then hit the slopes.
Have a few bevies in
Germany and hit the alps.
You know? That's what I want to do.
So and then I was like,
"Yeah, it's just the boys now.
Its just me and Mackey.
I'm gonna take him down a black."
And so I found one that,
he definitely didn't want to do it.
I was like, "Come on, let's do it.
Come on. I'll be fine. I'll be fine."
- Knowing Mackey he can't say no, right?
- He was like, "Ah."
He's like, "I wanted to do a harder slope,
but like not this hard."
I'm like, "Oh, it'll
be fine, it'll be fine.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Literally like this slope,
you can't see the bottom of it.
Like you can't see over it
until you start going down.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's like that steep.
- Yeah.
- And then when I started going on it,
I was like, "Oh, I think this is closed."
(laughing)
Because it hadn't been treated at all.
It was like all ice, it was
all steep ice, like crevices.
And like it was so steep
that when you'd go off a little bit,
you would just fall and
hit like a crevice, ice.
It took all my fucking
energy to get down this thing
without falling over.
- Yeah, that's fucking terrifying.
- I was absolutely exhausted.
I don't really get tired when
I go on like blue or red ones
'cause I don't really have
to use that much work.
I can kind of be lazy, but
on the really tough ones,
the amount you're turning,
you have to constantly
turn and throw your body
where the board is like, no, no, no,
we can't turn on this, it's too steep.
- Yeah.
- You have to force it
otherwise you're going too fast.
So I'm like knackered
and then I look up and I see Mackie just,
he gets up, fucking like
falls over, gets up,
falls over, gets up, falls over.
I was like, "Oh my God,
Meilyne's gonna fucking kill me."
- [Meilyne] I was lucky
you didn't have the GPS on.
- Yeah, Meilyne thought
I liked killed him.
She was like, "Oh my God, oh my God.
Connor's gonna kill him."
- Yeah, 'cause that was
on the second day, right?
- Yeah, second day.
- Yeah, 'cause like we
went our separate ways
on the second day
because I woke up, felt
like everything was aching.
Everything felt like shit.
But I was just like,
no, I'ma gonna still go.
- You're still pumped, right?
- I'm still pumped
because I really, really
wanted a second day.
So I was like, oh, easily,
fight through the pain.
What? It is just a bit
of muscle ache, right?
You can get through a bit of muscle ache.
So these guys go off to like
a completely different course.
- Yeah, there's like two
sides of the mountain.
- Yeah, there was like
two sides of the mountain
so these guys go on a
completely different course
and I'm just like, great.
I'll just be left to my own devices
and by the end of this day,
I'm going to conquer this beginner hill.
Right?
Because I felt like-
- Lift too.
(Garnt laughing)
- So Sydney had given up by then
and everyone else was on this other hill.
And on the second day it was
actually like almost empty
compared to the first day
'cause the first day was like,
I think like, it was
like a Sunday, wasn't it?
Or like a Saturday?
- Yeah, it must've been.
- It was like a public holiday I think.
And the second day wasn't a public holiday
so like the slopes were like almost empty.
- It was like perfect conditions as well,
there's like a shit ton of snow
and it was perfectly clear.
Sun was out. It was like, perfect.
- Nice, nice.
- So that was good.
- So I get up to the beginners
slope on the second day,
everything aching as fuck.
And I'm just like, it's fine.
All I need to do is like tumble once
and I'll just like fight
through the pain and you know,
get it over with.
So like I go down, right?
I start going down this beginner hill,
get further than I did yesterday-
- [Joey] That's good.
- I gotten more used to it
and then I tumble and
I was like, all right.
I'm like, you know, I expect this,
but like I tumbled and I landed
with my head like downhill.
So like I was like downhill like this.
- Yeah.
- Right?
And then I quickly realized,
oh, how do I get up?
(Joey laughing)
Right?
Cause my neck,
my neck muscles were not
working at that point
so I could not lift my
neck to go like that.
I was not only like,
I was lifting it not only like, you know,
even when I was like perfectly flat,
it was hard enough to lift my neck up.
No, I was going against the hill as well,
to lift my neck up.
So I quickly realized I
couldn't lift my neck up.
And I quickly realized how heavy
my gear that I was wearing was.
- Yeah, 'cause what I would
do is just, if I'm face down,
I just bring my board,
I do like a flip back.
- You can do a flip, but
you can also kind of just
like around turn your body around
like shimmy your way around.
- If you wanna be faster,
you can just fucking throw your legs
and just stamp it into the snow.
- Yeah, I did not have enough
ab strength at that time
to like lift my board up,
that's how much like how much
like my everything was achy.
- Yeah, of course.
- This episode of Trash
Taste sponsored by Manscaped.
- Father's Day is just around the corner
and you probably need
a gift for a hairy dad.
Make your dad proud this
year and get him and yourself
the Manscaped Lawn Mower 4.0.
You heard that right, Joey.
The Lawn Mower 4.0.
Get 20% off plus free shipping
with the code trash taste
at mansacped.com.
- Every time I go into
an onsen here in Japan,
I look around at all of
these men and think damn,
they're hairy as hell.
(all laughing)
They need some Manscaped in their lives.
- Particularly, the 4.0 Lawn Mower.
- Manscaped is the only
men's brand dedicated
to below the waist
grooming and just launched
their Lawn Mower 4.0.
Their fourth-generation trimmer
features a cutting edge ceramic blade
to reduce grooming accidents
thanks to the advanced
skin safe TM technology.
- The new wireless charging system
uses electromagnetic induction,
which helps the battery
length last longer.
- [Connor] Manscaped
also has the Weed Wacker
and nose and ear hair trimmer.
It's the best nose hair
trimmer on the market
and the perfect gift for your pops.
- Hey son, I want
Manscaped for Father's Day.
Thank you very much.
- Glad to know, dad,
that you can get Manscaped
and you can get 20% off
plus free shipping with
the code trash taste
at manscape.com.
- Don't forget that you
came from your dad's balls.
This is on script, everyone.
- I was the best load my dad ever shot.
(laughing)
- Back to the fucking video.
I kind of realized quickly I
was in a little bit of a pickle
because I didn't know
how I was going to get up
with all this heavy gear.
So what I tried doing is
just like slowly shimming,
what was I-
- Shimming.
- Shimming my body to be like horizontal
or something where I could get up.
That took ages.
I must've been there for
like 40 minutes, right?
- No one helped you?
- No, no, no, that's the point.
I was there for like a good 20 minutes.
And I'd gotten around like
I'd say about 20 degrees.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- If I saw someone upside down,
I would go over and be
like, "Yo, you good?
Homie, you good?"
- So after about 20 degrees,
like someone skis down
and says, "Are you okay?
Do you need any help?"
And I'm just like (panting)
"No, I'm okay. I think I got this."
(laughing)
So he goes, "Okay."
And he offers me a hand
and so I get up and I,
you know, he helps me sit back up
and so I sit back up and he goes back over
and I'm like, okay, I got this.
I try shimming a bit more, slip,
like my body slips a bit and
I'm like back on my back.
Right?
(Joey laughing)
And I had never known
how it felt to be like,
you know, when you see like
a tortoise on their back.
- Yeah..
- And they can't get back up.
That's exactly how I felt.
(all laughing)
- One with nature, man.
- And so I find after another 20 minutes,
I finally get to the point where my feet
is like I'm feet first downhill
and I'm just like fuck this.
I take off the snowboard and I walk.
I walked the rest of the way down.
I am not going through
that experience again.
- I will do whatever it takes
to not take the board off.
I'm like, I will do-
- Honestly, that's what I thought,
but I'm just like, it took
me literally 40 minutes.
- I just hate admitting defeat
and taking my board off.
- There's nothing sadder
than just like walking down
while everyone's just (imitates
swooshing) past you, right?
- Yeah.
- It was a depressing day.
- But if you have to do
it, you have to do it.
- It's crazy like everyone
snowboards in Japan.
It's really weird.
In Europe, everyone skies.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, Japan....
Yeah, for some reason-
- And no one was helmets.
- No.
- No one wears helmets.
- It's scary.
- Yeah.
- And the rental place
didn't even offer it.
- No, that's I-
- It's like an option you have to ask for.
- It's nuts and I was like,
"You don't offer helmets?"
- 'Cause I got like the rental pack,
which was apparently like
the all-inclusive pack.
And they just, yeah.
- Clearly not all inclusive, is it?
- I mean, like a beginner, you know,
even like professionals wear helmets,
you know what I mean?
- Exactly.
- You never know
what could happen, right?
'Cause fucking, what was it?
Michael Schumacher fell
and hit a rock, didn't he?
And then he's in a
vegetative state now I think.
- [Joey] Is he?
- And he was a really experienced skier.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, he just hit a rock.
- [Joey] Yeah. Yeah.
- I guess nobody told me
and I wish I...
(Connor laughing)
- I turned up and I'm like,
"Oh God, they don't have helmets."
(Garnt laughing)
- Scary.
- I mean,
I wish I had worn a helmet
so I could go the second
day without feeling like-
- It would help with your neck as well,
because you wouldn't be like-
- Yeah, I wouldn't be like fucking.
- Would it or would it just be
like extra weight on your head?
You're like, "Oh, God!"
- No, 'cause I feel
like that extra distance
you go that the helmet cushions.
- Oh, that's true, that's true.
- Definitely helps.
- Yeah, that's true.
- Also though, dude, skiing
and then being able to
get like a fat ramen
or a curry, oh damn, that's good.
- Oh yeah, like that onsen you go to
after a full day of snowboarding
is the best fucking feeling.
It is the best sleep you'll have.
- Onsen in this place,
was just like a view
of just like the ski slopes.
- Yeah, it was like an outdoor onsen
where you just viewed the mountains.
- And they like
refurbished it all as well.
- Yeah, yeah, you could feel
like the snow coming down.
Take me back, man. Take me back.
- Well, hopefully I'll be able
to join you guys this year.
- Yeah.
- Hell yeah. Hell yeah.
Dude, I want to ski so
God damn much this season
because I haven't done nearly as much
as I wanted to when I came here.
- Yeah.
Fucking dude, again,
like I haven't gone snowboarding or skiing
in like five years.
- Yeah and it's suppose to be
like some of the best skiing
in the world in Japan.
- Yeah.
Some of the slopes I walked
on is fucking insane.
- I would just want an experience
where I'm not on my ass for
literally 90% of the day.
That would be a cool
experience for me, man.
- Right, also just after
you're all like sore, you know,
you all go the onsen
then you go for the meal
and you get a bunch of beers.
Oh, it's so good, dude.
- Yeah.
- The after ski beer or
snowboarding is just like.
- Yeah, 100%.
- Yeah.
- Like how long did it take
you to learn snowboarding?
- So I always did skiing's
'cause my parents took me.
They do like the whole package holidays.
I fucking hated skiing,
because you'd ski in
like groups with like,
we'd go to like Bulgaria
where it's like dirt cheap
to like do it and you'd
have to be in a group
of other families.
And I didn't really enjoy it
'cause I was like the rebellious kid
so I wanted to do my own thing,
but you have to like go
and like follow along
and so I'd say it took me like,
before I got like good enough
to go on any slope skiing,
it was like three weeks.
And then I taught myself how to snowboard.
- Yeah, because once you've
gotten the grasp of skiing,
it's very easy to kind of,
because you're already used
to the lack of friction-
- Yeah, it was still really difficult.
- It's still hard, it's still hard.
- 'Cause it like didn't
make sense in my head.
- Nothing can prepare you for
just how snowboarding works,
because it really goes against everything
your mind has trained you for.
- I mean, especially the
difference between like skiing
and snowboarding, right?
'Cause like in skiing it's like,
if you're facing down the hill,
then you're gonna go and if you're not,
then you've stopped.
It's the literal opposite
with snowboarding, right?
You need to be facing the side
to go and this way you stop.
- But you know, the thing
that made me want to change
really badly was that I,
I'm sure anyone who skis will know this,
that the shoes are just fucking awful.
- [Joey] Ugh, the worst, the worst.
Concrete blocks on your feet.
- You know, 'cause we were doing like,
I'm really very grateful that my parents
took me on these like,
they were like the cheapest
skiing holidays you could get
so we often stayed really,
really far away from the places
and you'd have to put your ski shoes on-
- Yeah.
Kind of look like clown shoes.
- Yeah, so you put these
shoes on like 10 minutes
before you'd like, 10
minute walk from the bus.
So you have to walk.
I'm like 13 with my skis.
I'm not that strong yet.
Walking 10 minutes with my
skis in these horrible things,
click, clop, click, and
then have to wait on the bus
for 20 minutes and you have to walk
another like five minutes
and it's just like,
I hated it.
And then I was like, you know what?
I hate these shoes so god damn much.
It's so painful wearing them.
Everything about these suck.
- They absolutely destroy your ankles.
- Yeah, and then I was like,
I don't care what it takes.
I'm gonna learn to
snowboard for those God,
'cause you just get boots.
- Yeah, the first time I was
snowboarding boots, I was like,
"I can walk normally!"
- When you're at the restaurant, you know,
you see these people with their trays
like clopping with their
skis with their food on it,
and I'm like move out the way.
Chad snowboarder boots here.
- Runs past!
- Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, don't
mind me, just getting a beer,
I'll take that, thank you very much.
Its like you just get so much more freedom
and it's so much chiller,
like I don't know.
You haven't got poles to carry,
and so that's why I wanted to learn it.
I fucking sucked.
First three days, I
just kept falling over.
- [Joey] Oh yeah, same.
- Me and my little brother
did it at the same time
and my little brother sprained
his ankle like first day.
And I was like, no, I'm determined.
I'd say snowboarding the
first week that I did it,
I was pretty shit.
I could go down a black slope by the end,
but I was doing it really badly.
I was just like going like
this, you know, really slowly,
but like I went down it.
And then I'd say it took me like maybe two
or three more weeks before I felt like
I was actually doing it good.
- Hmm.
- Yeah, I was self taught.
- Yeah. I mean it's just
about like, you know,
just getting your body used
to those weird movements that-
- Yeah and going fast, speed.
- Yeah.
But also it's just like just,
you just have to commit to some of these.
Like you just have to be like,
I know this is not what
I'm supposed to do,
but I have to do this.
- Yeah.
- And it's scary, dude.
Like leaning forward on a hill,
like you're not built for that.
Your brain's not built to do that.
- Your brain's not built to be like,
you know this thing
you're going down fast?
You gotta lean forward.
- Yeah.
- Into the danger.
- Yeah, I always felt when I was skiing,
when you go fast, when you're skiing,
I almost feel like it's like
safer than going slower.
- Yeah, weirdly-
- It felt safer because like the way that,
I don't know how it worked,
but when I was going snowboarding,
when I started getting speed,
it did not feel like secure at all.
It's wobbling and anything
that hits the board underneath,
you feel it a fuck ton when
you're going really fast.
It is fucking terrifying.
- Yeah.
- And if you tumble when
you're going like really fast.
Oh my God.
You're just fucking
tumbling all over the place.
Yeah, it's like some "Looney Tunes" shit.
- And also like tumbling with
just these massive things
on your feet, it never
feels natural, you know?
It's like having two concrete bricks,
just like glued to your feet.
- It's like the green army man, right?
(all laughing)
- Just kind of learn, just of like do this
and then hopefully you fall good.
Just don't put your hands out.
That's the hardest part is learning.
When you fall naturally, you
want to put your hands out,
but that's when you sprain your ankles,
not ankles, your wrists.
- Your wrists.
- You can get like the wrist guards,
but they don't help that much.
- I mean, what I got taught,
'cause I got taught by like
a professional snowboarder.
and he said like, "When you fall,
like you have to fall with your fists,
'cause If you fall like
this it goes back."
- Just don't do that.
- He did that
and broke both of his
wrists at the same time.
So he's like, "Don't do
that, that shit hurts.
I can tell you firsthand."
- I just put my arms like that.
- Yeah, you just fucking
do this then you're good.
- Yeah. Just don't fall.
- Just get good, right?
- Why would I fall?
- No, literally what I
found from snowboarding
is that it's literally the
get good of sports, right?
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- If you're being taught by Mackey, yeah.
- Just don't be a pussy and just get good.
- I mean like when I
started getting used to it,
there was nothing that
could prepare my mind
like, you know, I watch YouTube.
When I watched the YouTube tutorials,
I tried to follow what they were saying,
but nothing could really prepare me
for just like getting
the feel of the snowboard
'cause it's like you've got to shut off
a part of your brain and
relearn another skill set
when you're like snowboarding and stuff.
- Yeah and also like just
while you're putting pressure
on your toes and your,
like the exact point,
can determine so much
on how you're steering.
You get so much more controlled
once you realize like, okay,
if I just have faith, I put pressure here,
it'll turn where I want it to.
But you kind of got to like
not panic to learn that.
- Yeah, panicking is what
fucks you up the most.
- Yeah.
- It's good though.
I mean, if you ever get
the chance to go, go,
but obviously-
- Honestly, yeah.
- I feel like it is a
very privileged sport.
(laughing)
- It is. Yeah.
We've been talking about a lot
of privileged activities, haven't we?
Like kayaking and snowboarding.
I remember when I was at the ski resort
and I phoned my mom said to tell her
that I was like snowboarding
and she was like, "Oh,
you rich now, are you?"
(all laughing)
'Cause to me, like snowboarding and skiing
has always been like the rich man's sport.
It's always been like the
white man's sport, you know?
- White man's sport. (laughing)
- Fuck, fuck.
- That's how I was raised up
to like view snowboarding
and skiing because you know,
when I go on holiday, you know,
I visit back home and everything,
but I go to like a nice cheap beach
or whatever in Thailand or whatever.
Snowboarding and skiing,
like the only reason I'd never gone before
was because there seems
to be like so many steps
and so much equipment that you need
in order just to go down a slope.
It's kind of like golfing, you know?
- Yeah, I was about to say,
there's two types of
rich white man sports.
It's you either go skiing and
snowboarding or you play golf.
- Well, I think I saw something
I don't know if this is true at all,
but I saw something and it was like,
it was like based on like
sports or accidents in general,
what percentage of them were white people.
And it was like the whitest
accident you can have
is on a fucking jet ski.
(Garnt laughing)
- I can't remember where it was.
It was like 99.5% of accidents on jet skis
were white people.
- White people.
- And then the next one was
skiing and snowboarding.
- Yeah, of course.
- It had like 97 or something.
- There's nothing more
white than a jet ski.
- I was gonna say when
you put it like that,
yeah, I don't think
there is anything whiter
than owning a jet ski.
(all laughing)
I mean, it's the whitest thing.
- Have you ever been on a jet ski?
- No.
- Have you thought about
going on a jet ski?
- I'd like to.
- Who the fuck owns a jet ski?
- I don't know.
- I don't live in like
Florida or shit like that.
- I've been on a jet ski.
It's fun as fuck.
- Really?
- Yeah, because I mean, in Thailand,
obviously with the beach and everything,
there's some services where
you can rent out a jet ski
for like a half an hour or whatever.
I mean, it's basically
just a motorbike on water.
- Do you jump off it?
- Huh?
(all laughing)
- Do you do a sick trick?
- SSX on a jet ski.
- You do any flips?
- Whoa!
(all laughing)
- No, I mean, it's just a lot of fun.
I could see how people get
injured on that though.
You go pretty fast and
you think that it's water
so it doesn't hurt.
- Water's like hitting concrete.
- Yeah, exactly, exactly.
- Yeah. You think.
- You think that falling
off at full speed,
it doesn't hurt, but it fucking hurts.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But it's a lot of fucking fun.
I mean, I haven't done much on it.
I mean, I've only had like
half an hour on a jet ski
on a beach in Thailand once,
but that's pretty much it.
- I feel like that's all I need.
I'd be like, "You know
what? Now I'm done."
- Yeah.
I've fulfilled the white man experience.
(all laughing)
- I'll tell you that this like
ski resort that we stayed at,
it was like, its theme,
like its theme was like,
it was very like inspired
by I guess like American culture.
(Connor laughing)
- That sounds so bizarre.
A Japanese ski result
inspired by Americans.
- By American culture.
- Yeah, it's really weird.
It was like kind of what I imagined,
what I imagine a ferry would be like.
You know, it had a lot of different,
a lot of different things.
- 1950s carnival style, I'd say.
- Yeah.
- Oh weird, in Japan?
- In Japan.
- Whereabouts did you guys go?
- Hokkaido.
- Oh, Hokkaido.
- But there was some areas of this hotel
that were like totally normal, chill,
but there's a big area that
was like kid's theme park.
- Yeah.
- Carnival theme.
It was really weird.
It was really fucking bizarre.
- So they had like
these animatronics, animals.
- Oh, like some Chuck E. Cheese shit.
- Yeah, exactly like that.
Like some Chuck E. Cheese shit, right?
But I don't know when they had
bought these animantronics.
because we were just, me and
Sydney were just sitting there
and they play these like songs, right?
They'd have these like
animatronic concerts,
like in this like children's area
where you can buy fucking
burgers and fries.
It was like an eating area.
- It was full on Chuck E. Cheese.
What the fuck?
- Yeah. Basically.
And these poor employees had to listen
to these fucking things sing all day.
- Yeah and so, me and
Sydney were just enjoying
like a nice burger and
everything like that.
Other than this fucking
animatronic dog or something
just starts bigging up the Confederacy.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What?
- Yeah and I was just like,
me and Sydney had to
double-take to be like,
did we just hear that correctly?
Like what is going on right now?
- Yeah, 'cause I walked past them
and I was like doing my own thing,
I'm like why they're wearing
Confederate soldier uniforms?
- Oh my God.
- Dead ass.
- Jesus Christ.
- So after we heard that,
we took like a closer look
at these animatronics, right?
To be like what is going on?
When did they buy these and
where did they buy these from?
And we saw one of the bears was,
it was very, let's say not very tasteful.
- 1920s black cartoon character.
- Oh no.
- Yes, yes.
- The lips were like massive, you know?
And it had the stereotypical
cartoon black man accent
with like 1920s, you know?
Like the whole, like I don't even...
It's literally if you go
and watch a Disney cartoon
from the 1920s with a black person
with that like kind of
like stereotypical accent
they gave them and
character, it was just that.
And it's like, oh no, oh no, oh no.
- Oh no.
Why?
You can't make that shit up.
- These poor Japanese tourists
are just like, "Ah,
American culture. Yeah!"
Kids are jut like running
around being like,
"Mama, what's the Confederacy?"
- Oh my God.
(Garnt laughing)
- Oh yes, Meilyne's got a fucking video.
- Can you show it to Joey?
- Nothing weirder than that thing
standing next to Miku.
- Yeah. (laughing)
- Like is that a Miku scene?
- [Meilyne] It was but I...
- What is this?
Oh no.
Oh no!
Oh, that is ugly.
- It was a really good resort though.
It's really cheap, good onsen.
- It was a really good resort.
- Really good resort but-
- Despite that, fantastic.
- Jesus Christ.
Oh.
- It is one of those things
you're like, "This is great.
What is going on here?"
- Why is this a thing?
Why is this here?
- Yeah.
- It's like you have your 90 year old aunt
who has that one piece of memorabilia
where you're like, "Auntie,
you should probably throw that away."
- You should probably not talk about that.
- Yeah.
You should probably
get rid of that I think.
- Yeah.
I mean, to give them
the benefit of the doubt
I don't think that anyone there knew.
- Yeah, they don't know.
- But it's the matter of like, you know,
when tourism comes back in, right?
- Oh, it's been there for decades.
- Well, clearly. Yeah.
How has no tourists come up and been like,
"You know what that is, right?
That's probably not a good idea."
- Yeah, I wanted to
think of like, you know,
because obviously in the
past five, six years,
it's been a very hot topic.
- Yeah.
- And it's only now where we've
really started to be like,
we should probably get
rid of all that shit.
- Yeah, it's not a good idea.
- So I wonder through, I wonder,
has anyone send them an
email, letting them know like,
"Hey, love the
animatronics. They're great.
They're really great."
- "The dog is cute but."
- "Maybe we should kind of
change up the theme a little bit.
We got a bunch of Miku's
probably lying around.
We could probably reservice them."
- That picture of the
Miku next to the dog.
I was like, that is some
cursed shit right there.
That looked photoshopped.
- I fucking....
I didn't want to like
swear off this place.
I thought it was, you
know, I'm sure, you know?
- There had to be a
reason behind it, right?
- It was a nice place
and I really did feel
like they were just like
ignorant, you know what I mean?
- Yeah, I mean, it kind of felt like
they had just like
brought some memorabilia
from America, they didn't
know what they were buying.
- Well, I mean this is Hokkaido, right?
A lot of the fucking ski resorts
are in the middle of nowhere.
- Yeah, it's in the
middle of fucking nowhere.
They have no idea about
anything like what's going on.
- It makes sense but it's still not good.
- It was just super fucking weird
because you walk into this-
- Yeah, it was really bizarre.
- You walk into this-
- It's the last thing you expected to see
in the middle of fucking nowhere in Japan.
- Yeah.
- Because we had to like,
we got to go on a coach that
lasted about two, three hours
in the middle of fucking Hokkaido, right?
So we were going in the middle
of nowhere and we walk in
and it's just like old American
memorabilia everywhere.
It was so fucking bizarre.
- It was massive as well.
The hotel part was really fancy as well.
So like the entrance to
this hotel was like marble,
like pure marble with like pillars
and it's like what the fuck?
It's so fancy you can get a helicopter
from the airport to the hotel.
- Fucking hell.
- Yeah.
- But then they just had this whole thing
that's like...
And then also, I mean,
completely unrelated,
but I was really offended when I bought a,
what was it, advertised as a coffee.
And I paid $3 for it.
And I'm like okay, it's not
the most expensive coffee,
but I was like, all right,
fine, paid $3 for it.
I literally dead I saw this woman
put a fucking shitty pod into a machine
and then click coffee.
I'm like, "I don't want it anymore.
- Was it a Nespresso?
- Was it a Nespresso at least?
- It wasn't even an Nespresso.
It was some budget version of Nespresso.
I was like what is this?
- I can't believe it.
- You know, if it's a Nespresso,
maybe I'd pay $3 for it.
- Not even a Nespresso.
- Yeah, that's like the bare minimum.
If you're charging for a coffee,
you know, I'm not expecting much.
But like if you're gonna put
the pod in fucking front of me,
like literally just get the
pod in front of me, boom.
- Right in front of my coffee. Really?
- Really? I was like I
don't wanna drink this shit.
Get this acid water out of my face.
I don't want to...
Connor showing his privilege clearly here.
- Yeah, yeah.
If it's a pod, get it out of my face.
- I've become spoiled
on coffee to the point
where I just can't like
drink the shit stuff anymore.
Like instant coffee, the
thought of drinking that now
like the one in the tubs.
- The Nescafe ones.
- Oh fuck, dude, fuck.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
I'm showing my privilege.
I don't even care, dude.
If showing my privilege means
I don't have to drink that again, gladly.
- Look at you, not
drinking instant coffee,
going snowboarding.
The true rich white man experience.
- It's not privileged,
it's called fucking taking care of myself,
not putting that fucking
dirt water acid into my body.
If you're still drinking
instant coffee, I get it.
If you're desperate, I always
have it in the cupboard.
If I'm desperate, I have
nothing else, I'll do it.
But if that's your like,
"Can't wait for my morning cup of coffee."
Puts acid in the hot water.
No, don't do that.
You're worth more than that.
Don't enable these companies
to sell this garbage shit
that they call coffee, it's not coffee.
Rant over.
(Garnt laughing)
- Ted Talk.
- Would you drink it?
- No, I don't drink it.
- Back me up here, boys. What the fuck!?
- I mean, you kind saying what I thinking.
- Yeah, the stage is all yours, man.
- Let the white man, fucking...
- Yeah, let the privileged white man
who just came back from
snowboarding say it.
- I just didn't come
back! It's fucking May!
Where am I gonna snowboard!?
(Joey laughing)
- Oh my God.
- No, 'cause like the worst part
of like staying in a hotel, right?
Is just knowing that you're
gonna have to like drink
that shitty instant three-in-one coffee.
- You mean that shitty coffee
that you have at the ryokan as well?
At camping?
- Oh God.
Don't remind me, man.
- So there's this coffee
machine in the ryokan, right?
- Okay. Hold up though.
The fact that there's a
coffee machine in a ryokan,,
is already....
There's normally no coffee
to be found in these places
- Yeah, usually there isn't, right?
So all of us, when we walked in,
we saw that and the guy was like, "Yeah,
so for people who are staying,
you get free coffee at
the coffee machine."
And everyone's like,
"Perfect. That's great.
Tomorrow morning's going to be fantastic."
Walk up and my first red flag was,
it was like "Free coffee."
And I was like-
- No, no, make me pay, please make me pay.
- There is nothing scarier
than something that's for free.
- 'Cause I was going to be like-
- Tea, (indistinct) that's fine.
- Yeah.
I was like it's a machine
that serves coffee
and you press the button
and you could hear beans grinding.
So I'm just like, surely,
surely there must be some quality to this
if I can hear something
whirring in the machine,
it's not just a pod or
something like that.
So I get this coffee, I drink it
and I'm just like, man,
I'd never thought I would ask for a refund
for a free coffee, but I'm
kind of considering it now.
- How was it so bad though
if it's like grounded coffee
if there's beans-
- I mean, I don't know if
it was grounded coffee.
They're might've just been like beans
just whirling in a container.
- I'm pretty sure they just grounded dirt
and they sold it as coffee
'cause that's what it fucking tasted like.
- I'm pretty sure those were rocks
that were being ground
up like from the dirt
that they dug up.
- It's like how some vacuums
have like speakers in them
to have like sounds play
when you pick up stuff.
Like to make it sound more-
- Yeah.
- It was not fresh coffee.
It was a lie.
- If it was beans, those
beans have been there
since those animatronics have been there.
- Once you grind the beans,
they go bad like within like, oh God,
I don't know how long.
Maybe like a few weeks.
- Well, clearly the people
at the hotel didn't know.
They're like, well, I mean,
once they're in the machine,
they're good to go, aren't they?
- Yeah, beans, they get
pretty bad pretty quickly.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- That's why it's just like
grind them when you drink them.
- Yeah.
- But clearly they didn't
think about that though.
Like, well, there you go.
Unlimited supply of
coffee right here for you
fine people staying at our hotel.
- Honestly, I will happily
be called privileged
for just wanting good coffee.
I'll take it. I'll take it.
'Cause I remember like-
- The most acceptable form of privilege.
- I was like, okay, so
if I'm privileged, fine,
I'm not a peasant then.
As long as I'm not a peasant, fine, fine.
- 'Cause like I remember
like I've grown up
my entire life on instant coffee.
Like my childhood was my parents
like drinking instant coffee
with powdered Coffee Mates, right?
And that was just my entire life.
I remember, like after
I finished university,
I had my first job, you know,
I tried try getting a coffee
machine for the first time.
And I remember the first thing
my mum and dad said to me,
was like, "Oh, you don't
need a coffee machine.
We got fucking Nescafe right here.
Just it's cheap."
- It's so easy.
- "It's easy, grind it up."
- Mother, I respect myself
and I'm not putting that dirt in my body.
- So one year I buy them for like,
I think it was, I can't
remember if it was Christmas
or one of their birthdays,
buy them a coffee machine, right?
I'm just like, "Mum, Dad, try this.
Just try it. Just give it a try."
- Just give it a go.
- And now every few weeks or something,
they're just like, "Son,
we need more pods.,
Son, where do we buy the pods?"
(laughing)
- It is so much better.
It's like night and day
how much better it is.
- Yeah.
- It's a lot more expensive obviously.
- That's what I'm looking
forward to in my new place
'cause my old place, I
didn't have enough space
for a Nespresso machine, right?
So I'm like, fuck the
curtains, fuck the couches,
fuck the beds, Nespresso machine.
That is the first thing
on my list right now.
- I said this on the live stream, bro.
I could lose my house and I'm like,
"Can I keep the coffee
machine at least though?"
- If my house catches on fire,
I'm taking the Nespresso machine.
- What do you save, your gaming PC,
all your life's work?
Nah, I'm grabbing the coffee machine.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
At least I can watch my house burn down
with a nice cup of coffee.
- With a nice cup of coffee.
- With a nice tasting espresso.
You know what I mean?
Fuck me.
- Oh my God.
- Honestly, I wish we did bring
a coffee machine on camping.
Fuck the TV.
- Yeah, I mean that's what the
power outlet was for, right?
- If you got a power outlet,
why would you not bring...
Fucking plug it in.
- I think that's what the
power outlet was for honestly.
- Plug it into Garnt's fucking
monstrosity of a generator
and bring an espresso machine with you.
Bring the milk frother too.
(all laughing)
- And bring the milk,
put it in a mini fridge,
connect the mini fridge
to your thing as well.
- I can just imagine, dude.
I step out of my tent, I'm like ah.
And I hear like (buzzing)
and I look over at
someone else's camping lot
and I see them with an espresso machine.
I'd be like, you fucking
10,000 IQ mother fuck.
I hate you so much right now.
And then he fucking froths the milk
and I'm like, "God damn it!"
- God, I wish that was me.
- Bringing a TV, weak shit.
Bringing your own espresso
machine and milk frother,
that's big brain, bro.
- That is big brain.
- Really the big brain stuff.
- The thing about
camping, I don't know why,
but like most food you cook on camping,
it tastes good, right?
- There's something about the camping cook
that gives you the taste to it.
- There's something about
just cooking something
on an open fire that
just makes it be like,
your caveman brain just activates
ad you're just like, "This tastes good."
- Bacon on campfire is like next level.
- Any meat on campfire is like legendary.
- The only thing that is just
never translated is coffee.
Coffee, like camping coffee
is just like the most, okay.
- Literally the headset meme
of the guy ripping it
off, campfire coffee.
I'm like. (sighs)
- Yeah, because let's be honest.
Camping is basically
just homeless simulator
for like a few days, right?
- I don't know about that.
- It's like privileged homeless simulator.
(all laughing)
- Have you guys ever seen
a homeless person before?
- It's like homeless simulator
with a savings account.
- Ah, trying to get us speed
run canceled over here.
(all laughing)
- What, by the homeless community?
(laughing)
- No, I mean, you're
basically going homeless
for a few days in the
middle of the field. Right?
- I mean, you got a tent, you
have a fucking power outlet.
Name one homeless person
with a power outlet, Garnt.
- Well, I'm not saying in Japan.
- Yeah, not in Japan.
- I'm just saying normally.
Like have you seen...
- I don't think homeless people are like,
"You know what?
I'm homeless, I'm gonna
retreat to the mountains."
They don't do that.
That's not what they fucking do
because they don't have a fucking tent
'cause they're homeless.
(all laughing)
- Oh my God.
- That's Skid Row.
- I mean, this is getting a bit off topic,
but I mean, yeah, I've seen
some homeless people have tents.
Do they not have tents?
- They do. (laughing)
They do and it depends
where you are though.
I mean, Skid Row, everyone
has a fucking tent.
- Yeah, they're all camping.
- Exactly.
- They're not fucking...
(all laughing)
Trash Taste canceled.
- I'm just joking.
I'm just joking.
- We apologize if any of these
jokes are very tasteless,
which they probably are.
- They probably are, it's all right.
- But no. What was I saying?
- Garnt's homeless simulator.
- It was homeless simulator.
Like there's nothing that has made me
just like feel more like... (laughing)
- Are you gonna say you feel grateful?
- I feel grateful that I
have a roof over my head.
- You are so fucking white right now.
- I feel grateful that I
have a roof over my head
and that I have a coffee machine.
- I spent one day in
the outdoors with a tent
with a power outlet.
(Joey grunting)
And I'm so grateful that I have all this.
- It wasn't a tent. It
wasn't a power outlet.
It was the coffee, which was
what I was trying to say.
(Joey laughing)
- So if you want to feel grateful
for your coffee machine, go camping.
- If I said that,
that would come off as
10 times more privileged
than if Garnt said it.
- Oh, come on!
You've said something
like that before anyway.
- I'm pretty sure he said
something five minutes ago
that was like that.
- And so what? I don't care.
I'm tired of pretending
to be a peasant, frankly.
It's never what I aim to be.
I remember when I was younger,
the moment I realized I was like,
this peasant life isn't for me.
I was like 10 years old. (laughing)
- 10 years old!?
- I don't fucking know, I don't know.
Arbitrary age of young age.
- Yeah, right.
- We went on a plane
somewhere and I was like-
- Wow, already privileged,
you get to go on a plane.
- That's not fucking, oh, come on.
It's like fucking Ryanair, it's
hardly a fucking privilege.
- You ever been on the EasyJet, Joey?
(Joey laughing)
That's the furthest thing from privilege.
- It was like a layover or something.
And then so this was like a,
it was a flight that was
going to like Australia,
but it stopped in where we
were going to, Amsterdam,
so it's like a two hour flight.
But I remember we were sitting
in an economy and I was like,
"Mum, what did they get
to go in the really,
really cool looking one?
They get to lie down."
They were like, "Oh, 'cause
that's really expensive."
And I was like, "Why
don't you pay for it?"
They're like, "We can't afford it."
And I'm like, "what do you
mean you can't afford it?"
- Just get a good bank account.
- I was like, "You guys
have a job. Right?"
And they're like, "Yeah,
we can't afford it.
It's too expensive."
I'm like, "Oh, well."
- If you were my kid, I would've
slapped you over the head.
- No, I was just asking, I
was like, "How much is it?
I don't know how much
it is. How does it work?
'Cause I'm young as fuck,
don't know how much it costs.
I have no notion of this before.
- [Joey] Right.
- I'm like, "Well, how much is it?"
(all laughing)
- How much and why can't you afford it?
- I'm like, "What?
So you're telling me that
those people over there
have enough money for it?
Nah, that's not right.
If they can get it, I can get it.
Fuck that."
That was like my mindset.
That's how I've always been in life.
I'm like, if someone else can have it,
I can have it, why can't I have it?
Why not? Why not?
If they get it, why don't I?
I'm a person too.
- I don't know,
did you think like that as a kid?
- I don't know.
I always thought if someone
else could do it, I could do it.
- When I was like 10 all
I thought it was like,
"Thank you father for buying
me a packet of Mentos."
- No, no, I was grateful,
but I would always wonder,
you never wondered why those other people
who had like all this stuff-
- I wondered but I was like,
well, the fact that
we're not there right now
means that they're different.
Right?
- Why? They're the same as us.
They just got lucky.
Fuck that!
That's what they want you to believe,
they want you to believe
they have like 10,000 IQ,
we earned this, fuck off, no they didn't.
They got fucking lucky.
Fuck off, no you didn't.
You made a few good decisions,
you made an air conditioning
company, good for you.
- How to get privileged? Just get lucky.
(laughing)
- There's a lot of luck involved.
- I mean, there is.
- It is mostly luck.
- 90% of the people in that first class
fucking born into wealth, bro.
It's bullshit.
- That is true, that is true.
- It's not fair.
It's the same rich people
giving each other their kids money.
I'm like, fuck that! I deserve that!
Why don't I deserve that?
- I'm gonna have some of that.
- What's wrong with having that mindset
of being like, if they can
do it, why can't I get it?
- I mean, there nothing wrong
with having that mindset.
- There's nothing wrong
It's just funny that you were
having that mindset like at age 10.
- Literally. Yeah, like from a young age.
- You were just trying to be a pro gamer.
- From a young age, - I always was like,
I just wondered like, why, why can't-
- Why aren't my parents
mid-maxing life right now?
- I just always thought if
someone else could do something,
always from a young age, if
they could do it, I could do it.
- No, that's great.
That's a great mentality to have.
When it's talking about,
you know, like privilege.
- Well it's because money's
like a taboo subject, right?
You can't say that you
want to get a lot of it.
I mean, I always just think that like-
- That's bullshit.
Like everyone wants to
have a lot of money.
- Yeah, of course.
- I mean-
- But no one wants to admit that, right?
- People don't want to
admit that they're like...
I mean, people are always
like, "If I had that,"
but they're never like,
"I'm gonna go for it,"
because it's embarrassing
admitting to your friends.
being like, "I'm gonna be a millionaire.
I'm gonna go for that shit."
Right?
'Cause it sounds, you're
like all right, all right.
- Yeah, all right.
- All right,
go back to Walmart.
Shut the fuck, you know what I mean?
It's like, nah, dude, fuck that.
Let people try if they want to.
Man, let 'em fuck up.
- Absolutely.
- If you're gonna go
bankrupt, do it before 30
so you can at least like
fix your shit, you know?
Like what was that?
I saw a thing that was like most people
the most impactful years in your life
are like 40 years old.
Like the people who do
the important things
or the CEOs of the
company, all that stuff.
It's when you're 40.
So just fuck up.
Try and do a bunch of shit.
- Yeah. Exactly.
- Honestly.
- Go for gold
when you're like 20, why the fuck not?
- Take some risks while you're young.
- Yeah, honestly like what I
try to tell people is like,
especially those in their mid 20s,
'cause I feel like
everyone hits the mid 20s,
like 23, 24 where they realize, oh,
I'm just gonna be working
for the rest of my life.
You know?
And everyone gets their first job,
you get excited getting your first job,
you're like, "Damn, I'm
actually getting paid for once.
I'm not a peasant anymore."
Because let's be honest,
being a student is-
- That's what the system
wants you to think.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- Being a student is just like, man,
you've just gotten used to
living like a peasant, right?
- Right, right.
It's like yes, this is normal.
- Yeah, you're just like,
I remember like somewhere in my mid 20s
when I just realized, man,
how the fuck did I just live off cup ramen
for a good like five years of my life?
That's not normal.
And I've just like internalized
that to be like, dude, dude,
Night out versus cup ramen.
Night out anytime.
- Yeah.
- Of course, of course.
Got to get your priorities right,
but then you realize, wow,
I have a job with a disposable income.
I can have like a decent living.
And that's what you would hope
that most people would have
if they went through university,
if they got an education.
It's a lot harder now.
- Oh yeah, absolutely.
- I was lucky enough to
get even my first job
after I graduated from uni,
which a lot of people have
a hard time doing now.
But I will say if you are
able to be in a position
where you can give yourself a
safety net, then by all means,
fuck up in your 20s,
because your 20s are the best point
where you can fuck up in life
and still it not be the end of the world.
- Yeah, you still have
enough time to recoup, right?
And like, you know, get
back to ground zero.
- Yeah.
That's what I was just
like, I was like fuck it.
Yeah. I'll try YouTubing.
It's probably a terrible idea to lose two
or three years of my possible
long engineering career to this.
But I was like fuck it.
I'm gonna try it.
Like why wouldn't I try it?
Like it'd be stupid for me not to try it.
- Yeah. Go for gold.
But I mean, it does get to a point where,
'cause I mean-
- I mean, if I went down
the engineering path,
I'm sure you too, you know,
eventually in your 40s,
you'd probably have a very cushy wage.
You'd be very well off.
- You'd be very comfortable, yeah.
- You'd have a very nice, you know,
you'd be able to afford
very fine things in life
when you become a chartered engineer.
The pay you get is very good.
- Yeah.
- And when you work
in certain places where the engineering
gets more difficult or whatever,
like you can start getting nutty money.
- Yeah.
- But I was just like, yeah, fuck that.
I'd rather take 20K a year
doing something that I like
that also has the chance to
make way more down the line.
And that's what I was always like though.
I always thought why settle?
I would rather risk losing it all
trying to make a million dollars
and then just settle for like, you know?
- [Joey] A comfortable
amount, right? Yeah.
- Because to me it's like, you know,
I can do that at any point in my life.
I can settle down and do things smartly.
- Yeah, because you never
know with our career, right?
Like it could start happening
tomorrow for all we know.
- Like if you become the
biggest fucking YouTuber
on the planet next week,
dude, you're set for life.
You know what I mean?
So it's like, but I don't
even think of it like that.
It's not like how I see YouTube anyway,
but I would just rather
risk and do something
that's kind of like oh,
could lose it all, hehe, XD.
(all laughing)
Could just become homeless tomorrow.
Fuck.
- Better start camping.
- Yeah, right? Better start
getting good at camping.
But like, I mean I'd rather try it
like yeah, fuck it, why not?
- Yeah, of course.
- I mean, I think it's important
to like recognize that some people
are just not in the
position to be able to try.
- That's true, yeah.
I was very lucky that
I built up the savings
and I also had a really
good family that set me up
to allow me to do that, you know?
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly, exactly.
- Because like I will say this right now.
Like I was never brought
up, like my family weren't
in the best of financial positions at all,
but like I was lucky enough
to have a mom and dad
who work their fucking asses
off to like get me through
and give me a better
opportunity than they ever had.
And that's why like right
now I'm trying to like,
most of everything I earn
I like spend on them.
I spend more on them than I do on me
because I feel like it's
my way of like paying back
the opportunity that they gave me.
- Such a good boy.
- Yeah, I mean-
(all laughing)
- Such a good son.
- I mean dude, like yeah,
I mean, my parents
like, especially my dad,
he came up from like
fucking poverty almost
in fucking Thailand and somehow
found his way to England
and worked his fucking ass off,
had a much harder life
than I ever went through.
So of course, I'm like fucking, dad-
- Isn't that fucking bad ass though?
Like he had a dream, move to England,
and then his son's like engineering degree
and now he talks about anime titties, but-
(all laughing)
That part of the story-
- That was not what I was expecting.
- That part of the story,
he doesn't tell that at
his family gatherings.
- Nah, he's fucking proud now, man.
- He's like, yeah,
(Garnt laughing)
Like that's such bad ass, dude.
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
- Because I feel like, you know,
it's a fallacy where
you think money solves
every problem that you have.
Money does not solve-
- It makes like significantly easier.
- Yeah.
- And it sounds so privileged
when you say that, but like, no,
as someone who hasn't
been poor in her life,
money doesn't solve every problem,
but there is a point in your life
where money is 90% of
your problems, right?
- Right.
- And once-
- Yeah, when money is your problem,
you don't really have time to think about
anything other than money.
- Yeah, exactly and like my
mentality when I was a kid
was just, I just want to get
by and be like comfortable,
you know?
- Same, same, same.
- I feel like that was
my big driving force
to like really try to be successful
and to take risks is just 'cause
I was just tired of just not knowing
what my life situation would
be five years down the line.
It's just like, how the fuck
am I gonna take care of my parents
when they get old?
That was a big fucking thing for me.
- There was definitely a time
when I was like 16 to like 18
where I thought I really love video games.
I don't really care what job I get.
I just want to be able
to play games after work.
That's what I genuinely I thought I wanted
for like a few years.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then when I went to university,
it like very much kicked in.
I was like, I don't think I can do
an eight hour job a day I hate.
- No.
- I think I can't do that.
- I did a three month internship to know
that I don't want to do this
for the rest of my life.
- Yeah, I mean, more
power to people who love
that line of work.
- Yeah.
- I was jealous.
At the time I was so jealous of the people
that loved my course
and what we were doing
because I felt like they
were just so OP with school.
They like got through it,
they got all the good opportunities
because they enjoyed it.
Like I just didn't enjoy
it, I couldn't try,
'cause I just didn't care.
- No, I have so much respect for people
who can go to their nine to five job
and be like, "Yeah, this is fine.
- At the time when I didn't
know what the fuck I was doing,
I was so jealous.
I was like, fuck man.
I wish I knew what the fuck I was doing.
- Yeah, right?
- You know?
And I'm sure for every
person like, you know,
I got very lucky and I
found something that I loved
and that just luckily makes money somehow.
My mom disbelieves that it
did for a very long time
but someone it makes money.
- I think all parents did
- Yeah.
- Somehow it makes money, right?
And you know, I'm sure for every one of me
that got very lucky, there
was probably 10 people
who've never really found what they liked
and just had to like kind
of just be like, "All right,
well I gotta get a job.
I can't do nothing all my life."
- Yeah, exactly.
- It sucks.
- I think one thing I've realized more
as I've grown older is that as a kid
we were sold this idea that
there's only really one way
your career path can go, right?
It's like education, university,
you get a job to do with your degree
and your career progresses from there.
And that's like, I had that mentality
for like the longest time of my life.
And now like the older I've gotten,
the more people I've met
who have had like the
weirdest fucking career paths.
- I mean, Ladybeard.
- Yeah, yeah.
- We've had a lot of those
people on the podcast.
- I feel like in the
entertainment industry,
you do meet the people who
kind of are just bouncing
from things to things.
- They're just try to figure
out what they want, right?
- Just trying to enjoy life.
- Not even in entertainment,
just like living in Japan as well.
Like meeting like teachers who
have like found opportunities
just randomly, like sometimes,
like what I'm trying to
say is that as a kid,
I was, you know, we got
put this pressure on
that by the time you go to university
or by the time you finish high school,
you need to know what you want to do
for the rest of your life.
- I wish they didn't
fucking tell me that lie.
- Yeah, that's bullshit.
That is 100% bullshit.
- That is the biggest
lie of the fucking world.
I feel, especially when
you're a young adult,
the biggest lie of the fucking world
is thinking that once
you start a career path,
that you're gonna have to stick on this
for like the majority of your life
and that's such a fucking lie.
And like another big lie is thinking that
you need to go to fucking
university or college
to have to have a decent career.
That's also a fucking lie.
There are so many different career paths
that are available to you
that is not just higher education,
because as an Asian, I was taught that
if I don't do higher education,
I'm a fucking failure.
- If I don't get that
A, I failed as an Asian.
- I'm not even talking
about being a YouTuber
'cause obviously we are very lucky
to be able to be YouTubers.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- I'm not even talking about like,
oh, we're YouTubers.
That's a different career path I found.
No, I've met like so many other people
who have like just found random jobs.
I mean, fucking Meilyne
found her fucking job through Craigslist.
(Joey laughing)
- It is about just trying and looking
and just being at the right
place at the right time
and making sure you take every opportunity
that comes your way.
- Exactly.
- Like I just say yes to everything.
- Yeah.
You miss every opportunity you don't take.
- Yeah, man.
- Yeah.
- And if you, which is in the UK,
which is something that I
just did read and enjoy.
It was like the culture of you go to work,
you go to the pub and that's it.
Like you never try and
do any self improvement.
You never try and like look
for any other opportunities.
Like looking for another
job is like, oh wow,
what's wrong with you?
- Yeah.
And like there are so many
opportunities out there
for different jobs that you
like never even thought about
until it's just on your lap.
Like have we ever talked
about Kenny before?
Like your friend?
- No, I haven't talked about Kenny.
- What he's doing?
- Oh yeah. Kenny's my friend
who's lives in Niigata.
And he's a crazy guy.
He's great. I love him.
He's amazing. He's so funny.
He's really, really rich.
- He is a proper lad, he is.
- And he's up in Niigata
in the middle of Japan
and he's half Japanese, half Welsh,
and he's just a fake priest
and I think I've spoken on it before
that my friend's a fake priest.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- But like he teaches English
and then he's also a fake priest
and that's just what he likes doing.
But he also just doesn't really care about
being in one place for too long.
He's like, I'll just kind of go wherever-
- Just a wanderer.
- He literally just goes places
and he's like, "All
right, what's going on?
Let's figure it out. Let's
try and get a job here."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- He just doesn't give a fuck.
- I have a friend who is
similar to that who lives here.
- I couldn't do that.
But he's bad ass, he just turns up
and does what he wants, it's great.
And he's always super
happy and super optimistic
and I'm like, "Are you
British? Are you really?
You grew up in the UK, right?
How are you this optimistic?"
- It's the Japanese side that's kicking.
- Yeah, he just turns up.
He's like, "Yeah, what's going on?"
Always has a good time,
talks to anyone he meets.
It's just like, yeah.
- I feel people like that are usually
like the most optimistic
people in the planet, right?
Because I have a friend
like that who was like,
he's an animator for an anime studio here.
He did like the,
I met him through like
the Pop Team Epic stuff.
But like he also just like goes out.
He's just like, "I'm just
gonna go on a road trip
for a month and just like
try and make some money
along the way and just see what happens."
And he comes back with all
these like insane stories
of just like him on the
road and being like,
"Yeah, I just like walked
into this like random cafe,
got a job for like two days
and then got some money
and used that for fuel just
to go to the next place."
I'm like that's so fucking cool
because I can never fucking do that.
I could not bring myself to just be like,
I don't know where I'm gonna be tomorrow.
- Yeah.
- I don't know
what I'm gonna do tomorrow.
I couldn't do that myself.
- Yeah,
I couldn't do that either.
I need like some,
like at least a little bit of a plan.
- I need some kind of direction.
Yeah, yeah,
- I like plans. I like plans.
- I like plans.
- I used to like spreadsheet
all my like spending
in university, like to the penny
and I would have like a prediction
of my spending coming up
and what I was allowed to spend
and literally everything in a spreadsheet.
And then when I started like,
my YouTube start giving me
some money in university,
I was like, "Oh my God, this is amazing."
I was like, "I don't need
the spreadsheet anymore.
Fuck this."
Why am I like spending hours a week
updating this fucking spreadsheet?
It doesn't fucking matter anyway
'cause I'm not gonna spend that much.
- Yeah.
- It doesn't fucking matter.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah.
- Yeah and like to go
off what we were saying.
I'm not saying like there's no place
for higher education and
university or everything-
- I'm still glad I went.
- Yeah, I mean, I'm still glad I went
but what I'm saying is like
don't feel the pressure to need to go
just because you don't know
what you want to do with your life.
That's the big thing. Right?
'Cause it's such bullshit
that by the time you hit 18,
it's just the expectation
where it's just like
you need to know what you're doing now.
Your birthday has ticked over.
You are now an adult.
You need to know everything now.
- There are 30 year olds
out there, 40 year olds
who don't know what the
fuck they want to do.
- Yeah.
- The guy who like founded
McDonald's was like 40 years old.
- Yeah, right.
- Yeah, it's like I don't
really feel too bad about it.
You know, like I said earlier,
the most productive years of your life
are like 40 years old.
So as far as I'm concerned,
you're just fucking up
until you get to the point
where you can like actually do shit.
- Yeah. Exactly.
- Yeah.
You're just fucking up enough
until you found out a way
to not fuck up, right?
- Build the foundation of the character
you want to be, you know?
- It all goes back to
the snowboarding, right?
Like just tumble a couple of times
until you learn how to not tumble.
- Damn, what a good ending.
- Wow.
- Cue credits.
- Get good, get good in life.
- Well, with that amazing
segue, thank you, Joey.
Let's check out the patrons. Look at them.
- Wow.
- They're beautiful.
- Wow, look at all
these lovely patrons.
- Beautiful patrons.
None of these are peasants.
- None of these are peasants.
They all own Nespresso machines.
- None of them are homeless, right?
(Joey laughing)
Hopefully, hopefully, hopefully.
- Hopefully.
- I'm getting out of here
before we get canceled.
See ya.
- But hey, if you'd like
to support the show,
then make sure to go to
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your memes on the subreddit.
And if you hate our faces,
listen to us on Spotify.
- Bye!
- Where the fuck
did Connor go?
- [Connor] I'm leaving
before I get canceled.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- It's too late, Connor, it's too late.
- It's too late.
- We're all canceled.
- All right, well, thanks for watching.
I've been boss man one with boss man two
and no longer here, boss man three
and we'll see you guys
in the next episode.
Bye!
- Bye.
(upbeat music)